Me.
Uh,
let me tweet it again.
Hold on for is it at the beginning?
We'll be unscrewed as I used.
dream.tv Ford Slash Joe Rogan.
That's not bad.
My typing is not bad for an ape for dumb monkey motherfucker like my,
hello everybody.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by stamps.com
stamps.com is a way to easily do a lot of the shit that you do at the post
office in the comfort of your own home.
stamps.com allows you to print up real us postage on your actual computer with
your home printer.
Real easy shit and it allows you to do it in a way that you measure all your
packages.
The postman comes,
you've got all this stuff printed from your own home computer,
you give it to him and you're done.
You don't have to go to the post office.
You don't have to wait in the lines.
You don't have to deal with the nonsense,
the post man.
If you're in a place where the post man can pick it up,
you can just leave it out there and give it to him or you know,
you might have to drop it off in a mailbox or a post office,
but what you don't have to do is wait in line.
You don't have to weigh your own shit.
You don't have to do any of this stuff.
That's super annoying about going to the post office and if you use the code
word j r e you get a free digital scale and up to $55 of free postage and you
get to try this $110 special offer@stamps.com where you will see how easy and
convenient is and you will say,
God damn it,
Joe Rogan,
how did I live without this stamps.com and I'd be like word
stamps.com what the fuck?
That's very relevant.
Sit.
I'd be like,
go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type in j r a that's
stamps.com enter j r e and a get your $110 bonus offer,
which includes a digital scale and up to $55 of free postage.
We're also brought to you by Squarespace.
Squarespace is a website that that's any silly bitch like yourself.
Construct a beautiful website of your own without having to have any html
skills,
any skills,
and learning how to construct things with,
you know,
website programs.
That shit you don't have.
You don't need any of that anymore.
Squarespace allows you to do it all online.
You can try it before you even sign up for this.
The most beautiful thing about it,
you don't have to give your credit card information to try it.
He just try it.
Try and build yourself a website and you're like,
oh shit.
Joe Rogan was telling me the truth.
And then you use your credit card.
Exactly.
Then use your credit card and um,
and get yourself a beautiful website that you made yourself.
Go to squarespace.com and entering the code word Joe.
That's j o e super easy to use.
You could set up an online store very,
very easily.
You can,
if you're a musician,
you can actually sell digital music.
Squarespace,
they have it set up specifically for that simple drag and drop interface.
Beautiful designs.
The offer 24 seven support.
And a Squarespace is a,
also a company that's owned by a bunch of cool motherfuckers.
I met them in New York.
The uh,
all the people behind the company could not be cooler,
which always makes you feel better that you're in business with some cool
people.
So a squarespace.com and enter in the code word j o e and get yourself a website
son.
Isn't it about time?
You Lazy Bitch.
Well,
you could do it all on Squarespace before you actually pay for it and figure out
what come on and put your time into something productive.
Go,
go get it.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible] Dot Com that's o.N ,
n.
I.
T.
Speaking of productive,
if you want to prepare yourself properly,
incorrectly for the upcoming Zombie apocalypse,
there's no better way than some Zombie kettle bells pitch.
Get Ahold of these Zombie kettle bells.
You can use them to work out while you're watching the walking dead.
That's how our rocket back watching the walking dead.
Those motherfuckers,
I told him I was done,
they dragged me back.
I'm never,
I never got hit dude.
Start with season one.
You'll get,
you'll get hip.
I'm about to be on the road.
I probably will.
Yeah,
get it paid off for an iPad or something like that.
That's how it usually you guys how I got on breaking bad seasoned ones.
Continue.
I understand you're doing businessmen.
That's all right.
This is no big.
This business is like that.
This business requires that kind of conversation.
They are so comfortable.
He just jumped right in.
That's what this business requires.
A,
we also have,
uh,
the,
my favorite ones are the primal collection.
The,
um,
the gorilla is my favorite,
so I just love the idea of working out what a gorilla and you can get a c Urias
workout with one 70 pound kettle bell.
That's what I use most of the time for most of the things I do.
That one 70 pound gorilla kettle bell is a mother fucker.
God Damn,
that puts you through a serious workout.
It gives me tired like nothing else except Jujitsu.
Jujitsu is the only thing that wears me out like a brutal kettle bell workout.
Renegade rows with two seventies.
Come on son.
Anyway,
I'm going to get that bitch one,
that little holler.
She's not a bitch.
It's just a tiny little monkey man.
You don't have to be mean.
That one's going to bite your dick off.
She's a nut biter.
The chimp already bit your Dick off.
But the howler monkeys,
a nut biter,
she's right about to clamp down on your favorite ball.
Bang,
look at her.
But if you have never at worked out with Kettlebells,
I really actually would suggest that one and don't feel like a bitch because
you're using something that's 18 pounds.
You can actually get a really good workout in because a lot of is using your
body weight to support these and doing large repetitions.
Please.
If you're going to learn how to do something like this,
get a trainer or at the very least,
start with a really lightweight and watch some instructional videos online and
really watch what you're doing because a,
it's your form is very important to keep yourself from getting hurt.
I've been doing kettle bells for more than a decade.
I've never been hurt lifting kettle bells.
That's incredible.
I mean,
it's just my personal experience,
but if you do it correctly with good form and you don't get crazy and you warm
yourself up correctly,
you know,
uh,
I think it's probably one of the safest ways to lift weights,
but learn how to do it correctly.
It's also one of the most beneficial when it comes to your ability to use it in
a sport or any kind of physical activity or just for regular shit around the
house.
Being able to pick up a couch,
you know,
being able to lift things that are heavy.
The the kind of weight lifting strength that you get from kettlebells is a full
body strength.
It's one of the,
one of the best exercises for improving athletics because when you're using
something that requires you to use your whole body to lift,
then your body gets used to working as a unit as opposed to like the way they
used to do it in the old school bodybuilder days where some people still do with
where they isolate,
you know,
like today I'm going to do biceps and triceps and tomorrow I'm going to do
calves.
Bitch,
that shit is,
you're going to,
you're going to have a bunch of confused muscles that don't know how to work
together.
Everybody's strong,
but nobody speaks to each other's language.
You ever see like a really big goofy bodybuilder guy tried to try to fight,
try throws punches of people.
They fall down,
they're all tipsy there.
The whole body's designed fucked up.
It's like there's too much weight up there.
They're seeing one of them try and comb their hair,
clean their ass.
Ah.
Some of them are so big these days that they kind of keep getting bigger.
I guess that's how bodybuilding works.
I mean I guess that's what it is,
right?
The biggest guy now it's like who's the biggest freak and those the,
so every year they get bigger and bigger.
Right.
Um,
I'm still in the Swartz nigger days of my knowledge.
Nobody building it.
Isn't it funny that that's when they had it right?
That's when they had it right.
Like in sports negative at a ton of shit too.
Like he talks about how he did a ton of steroids but he,
his physique was incredible and impressive but not excessive in the point that
you have today.
You know like today you have these guys that are just 90% steroids.
Like you look at their body,
you're just waiting for like steroids DePaul out of their father,
their ankles like them to be standing in a puddle of stuff.
Like pull up a picture.
The dividends between Arnold Schwarzenegger and whoever the newest,
latest Mr Olympia guy is.
Cause they,
they,
these motherfuckers is just getting ridiculous.
It looks like their skin is stretched so thin.
It's just going to like burst.
It does this so unreal.
It's so unreal what they look like now Kona look,
get the black and white ones in him.
Bodybuilding was when he was in his prime.
Like look at that.
I mean obviously a fucking huge,
huge man.
I mean the dude has got damn enormous.
That looks almost like a pain shooting.
Dope does not look fake.
We shoot,
it's a painting.
That's a painting.
It's a painting,
right?
It's hard to see in this resolution went.
That's real.
That's lit shit.
What does this click for?
Full resolution.
Oh,
it's one of those stupid websites,
but they do with the,
that's why you never want to get all sports.
And they were famous.
I'm not gonna have a website that's just a scam and they click on it like the
one scroll down.
Scroll down there.
The one,
no,
no.
A little,
little further.
Little further.
A little further.
A little farther down.
There's some,
yeah,
like get those ones.
That one right there with him on stage with his arms stretched out with all the
people behind him.
Yeah,
there you get a good image.
Okay.
She's Christ.
But perfect example because holy shit was he fucking enormous,
right?
Yeah,
but not compared to today.
No,
it's not ridiculous,
dude.
That big today on the street.
Yeah,
or in the UFC.
Absolutely.
Well not really.
I guess sorta like glaze and t bowels pretty fucking big,
but not built like that.
I mean that's just one image of Arnold.
He was pretty fucking massive.
There's a few guys that are big like Tyron Woodley who's a badass welterweight.
He's real big,
but now I'm like that.
It's a different kind of big,
they're,
they're like,
they're like super athlete big.
This is like a different thing.
This is like all this sports in nigger six one or six two I think
I met him.
I met him recently at the UFC.
It was cool as fuck.
Oh,
you're doing doing an excellent job.
Like thank you.
I didn't get even cited like I'm holding hands with auto.
Fuck.
It's worth the nigger.
I'm like,
this is crazy.
Nobody got no prize when Arno,
so here's the current guy,
I'm a fan.
Here's the current Chi.
Can I count?
I guess muscles,
muscles have muscle.
My God,
that guy's fucking ridiculous.
Sleep pig.
It's like there's muscles that don't even exist there.
I'm like,
he's kind of hand muscles.
Lift his hand muscles.
Have you ever seen anybody with hand muscles like that?
It was mostly there's more muscles in his hand and there are in my torso.
Let me just tell you one thing that that guy works hard.
No doubt about it.
Ladies and gentlemen,
that guy does a lot of lifting and does everything scientifically incorrect,
but what's fucked up is you can't even get there without steroids.
You can't get there.
That doesn't exist.
That's not a destination on your navigation system.
His muscles look like they need to be ironed.
It look wrinkled.
The only way you can get that big without the juice you'd have to,
the skin is stretched so much.
That's what those lines are.
It's like the skin looks like you could just tear it.
That's the striations of the muscle tissue underneath the skin.
The skin is just so thin because they're credit,
incredibly dehydrated,
not just low on fat,
not just massive amounts of muscle but insanely dehydrated.
That's not possible without a bunch of different factors and that look is
extremely unhealthy.
That's really more performance art to me than it is like a sport.
Oh my,
I got the eye when I was competing in taekwondo tournament so I got down to four
and a half body weight,
four and a half percent body weight,
body fat by a caliper.
Now I've been told recently that that shit is not very accurate like calipers.
Like you really got to get dunked underwater or do electrical thing.
So you know I said four and a half percent and a bunch of people correcting me.
Thank you for correcting me cause I didn't know that the calipers were so bad
but that's what they told me.
So like that would probably be like 7% or something like that.
If I was,
I was super,
super lean,
but nothing compared to these guys what these guys are doing.
I
was,
I was working out with these guys are doing is like getting real close to death
while keeping giant muscles.
It's fucking madness.
Like this is the nuttiest fucking sport of all time.
Yeah.
It's performance art.
This duck,
I will rip your Dick Clean Ass doors.
Those bank vault ass doors of his,
just
charge our bags on a.com.
Oh and and it,
we don't sell steroids.
We deal cell test Asta t plus a testosterone booster that uh,
we,
we've,
we've got some initial test results back that are very positive.
I don't,
I don't want to tell anybody,
you know,
what works or doesn't work.
It gets real tricky when it comes to soft bones,
especially when you're selling them.
But there are some ways to,
to boost your testosterone.
There's a bunch of different ingredients that,
you know,
nutritional ingredients that have been known and shown in certain studies to,
uh,
have a positive effect on testosterone production.
So because of that,
because it's so controversial,
all on him at supplements contain a research page.
So if you go there and you're like,
wait,
what is this stuff?
Like,
why does this work?
You can go and research,
you can read the research page and it's referenced.
We have references for all the different supplements we have.
We just recently released a press release on a Alpha brain.
We get the first of our clinical results back,
the first that we can report.
And um,
they showed positive results in two different categories in,
in memory and in executive function,
which I f I believe that's the term executive function,
which I believe means your ability to do things quicker.
What I've shown,
what I've found myself is that when I take it at form sentences better,
I know that sounds like horseshit,
but your mind runs on a foundation of nutrients.
Your,
your mind and your body,
the whole thing,
the whole package together,
the more healthy it is,
the better it runs period.
And there's certain aspects of health and nutrition that had been shown to
enhance cognitive function,
but we did when constructing Alpha brain is we isolated or we got the isolated,
um,
ingredients from the best vendors we can find and all this stuff that's been
shown to have a positive benefit of cognitive on cognitive impact.
We also put them together in a way that we think will work synergistically as
this is designed by people that really know what the fuck they're doing.
And again,
all the research for it is on,
on it.
And listening to me do the,
a description of it is never,
never as good.
That's why I like it.
Went to Aubrey's here to explain it.
I take it,
I take all the different,
the different shit that we sell in on it.
And if I didn't think it was any good,
I would,
I wouldn't tell it.
I don't think that you should live your life selling people things that don't
work.
But I think that if you do sell things that you use and you,
you,
you find a good product and you find something that's actually beneficial,
sell it to people.
And that's what we do it on it.
And we describe ourselves as a human optimization website.
Go to o,
n n I t use the Codeword Rogan and save 10% off any all supplements.
Boom.
Schelok log.
My man Everlast is here,
ladies and gentlemen,
Cue fucking music
experience.
I always threatened,
I was threatened to move the fuck out of la,
but the problem is I know too many cool motherfuckers that live in la.
I moved down to La.
I still make it work.
Yeah,
but you do,
but you don't mean you could drive here.
It's not far.
I mean,
I don't live here either.
The,
you know,
the thing about living,
we live in the greater la area,
the southern California area is that,
you know,
you and I can exchange text messages.
Hey,
what are you doing man?
We doing Tuesday,
let's do it.
What's so Monday?
Boom.
You come in and that's it.
It's on.
I mean that's somebody on Twitter was like,
when are you going to be back on?
I was like,
you know what,
show I'm about to leave town.
What's up?
Well you just got back,
right?
He did.
We were on the road for awhile.
Yeah,
I've been back since,
you know,
I've spent,
Christmas with the fam and been home pretty much since little spot date here and
there.
I leave for Australia Saturday.
Australia are there for a couple of weeks.
Uh,
you can find all of them dates on the twitters where you stop and wait.
Where are you going first?
Oh you a couple nights in,
uh,
Sydney and then we move on to like Brisbane,
Melbourne,
if you're on the place.
And then we wind up in Sydney again.
You know,
we,
I got a couple of like multiple night gigs in a few towns.
I got to get out there and do stuff and you know,
more Rogan,
you know,
after shocks now.
All that kind of,
I was just telling my boy today,
man.
It was like,
so again,
I know I've said it on here.
Performers.
I never did.
The acoustic thing has like other than going in a radio station and promoting a
record,
okay,
we'll come do an acoustic version.
When I started doing it.
Here is when it like you don't went.
This could be an interesting show that,
that'd be an interesting time for me and the audience and it's just,
I've been,
that's all.
I've been doing it for the last like year and a half.
It's just a different vibe,
you know?
It's a cool vibe.
There's something about acoustic songs too for me,
you know what I mean?
A lot better.
What is it?
You know,
it's a completely,
it's more is not always better.
You know,
more shit in the background.
More drums,
more.
Sometimes a song could be insanely profound,
but just a little bit of guitar and us and a voice,
you know?
And I'm sure you want to produce my next record,
male,
just promote,
dude,
I'll help you on here.
I'd like,
that's a beautiful thought.
Right.
But you know what I mean?
I think that there's a lot,
you know,
like you ever listen to a song and you go,
well they didn't need that electronic bullshit in the background.
The song could have been fine without all that stuff.
Occasionally.
I mean,
I don't really listen to a lot of new music anymore unless it gets somewhere
where it pops on my radar.
You know what I mean?
Like I don't dig for like what's new,
what's happening,
but mostly what I listen to is old.
So it's harder to look through that old classic stuff and be like,
they shouldn't have done that.
Occasionally I'll hear something on the radio and be like,
man,
that's a really good song.
I wish they wouldn't have done this part or something.
You know what I mean?
But you know what,
there's some albums that have their,
they're so intricate and there's so much going on,
but yet it's perfect.
Like Zeplin like think of like Zeppelin three things.
Think of like a whole lot of love.
Think of like that song.
Yeah,
I mean,
and it really isn't that much going on and know as you think.
they only had 16 tracks.
They have a whole two minutes of fuck sound.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
you mean like going over the top,
which is crazy.
The symbols and the background and they added a bunch of stuff to their music.
But yeah,
I see what you're saying.
As far as the actual song,
they actually did all of that,
don't you know what I mean?
So you know,
so it's good.
And they re they replicated it.
Sometimes I think like cats overproduced their records to the point where they
can't recreate them.
You know,
like,
um,
like I'm a huge Chris Cornell Fan.
Like,
you know,
Soundgarden and Chris Cornell like,
right.
Like occasionally he would make a record and he'd make it so beautiful with the
voices and all the extra production of singing on top of his voice and
compliment,
you know,
all these,
nobody could sound like him.
So it's like hard for you to go out and emulate your voice.
Got Real production.
You did.
You know what I mean?
I went,
it's raw,
it's fun,
it's amazing.
You know what I mean?
But sometimes like I remember like especially that one,
uh,
like the land,
this big split Supernova record where like black hole sun,
they were beautiful songs but like live,
it was like you missed a lot of that extra,
um,
pomp and circumstance of the song,
you know what I mean?
So it just sometimes I think that that's what,
when you,
and especially I want to make an a record that's like where you,
when do you stop?
That's really kind of,
and the acoustic stuff eliminates all that.
I wrote the songs acoustically,
so it was just like doing them how you wrote them,
you know?
And,
and so there's that line of when you go too far,
it's like that lion and what's that?
There was that movie with Will Smith,
his first movie where the guy had the paintings and stuff and he was,
had this dream about all the kids writing,
making these beautiful,
masterful paintings.
And he asked the teacher,
how do you teach them?
They're all painting Rembrandts and Matisses and this.
And she said,
I just know when to take them away from him.
You know what I mean?
And that's kind of what a producer is in the,
in the music studio is like knowing what's not there sometimes,
but always knowing when to stop,
oh no,
this is done,
that's finished or we need to take some of that away and there it is kind of
thing.
Yeah,
I would think that that would get real tricky man.
I would think that would get real tricky,
especially when there's more than one vision.
Like you got a producer comes in and they have an idea and you have an idea and
maybe the guitarist has an id and this guy has an idea.
Well luckily my,
I'm the only writer and stuff and my stuff most of the time I have cats that
right with me occasionally,
but they're my songs and I'm doing them.
But like for me or producers always been an adversarial relationship.
It has to be,
it has to be from me.
I want a producer.
I mean,
cause I didn't have one on the last record because I finally am to the point
where I can challenge myself.
I need,
I always needed that guide where I was,
you know,
ah,
it's good enough.
No it's not.
And,
and now it's like I got to that point where it's like I can tell myself when
it's not good enough and keep going.
Like I'll do the 20 takes instead of five,
I'll do the,
you know what I mean?
I've gotten that Pharma,
but that was always what a producer did for me from when it was started with,
you know,
my first producer,
a guy named bill,
the Al Bashir there.
It was always kind of like that.
It wasn't good enough.
That was the guy they in the room to make you better.
You know what I mean?
And for me,
the only way you probably got that out of me was kind of challenging me or
charge me up a little bit.
You know what I mean?
You suck mugs.
Mugs used to be the straight guy.
I get punched in the bus,
stop you while you're doing it.
Punched the button,
be like,
Yo,
that really sucks man.
Do what he can.
And you'd just be like sitting there like,
wow man,
fuck,
all right,
cool.
All right.
You know,
and you shake it off and you do it again.
But it makes for it toughens you up in the studio,
which you need to be in the studio.
You can't be some,
you know,
you're the best things always happen when if you get through a whole record and
nobody's challenged your ideas,
you didn't make the best record you can make.
You know what I mean?
It's like if you go and work out and,
and you don't have that buddy there that pushes you to do those extra two or
can,
you know,
you're not going to,
you're going to walk away and you might not have done as many as you could.
Yeah,
I see what you're saying.
What,
I mean,
I think there's a,
there's a parallel with comedy too.
I'm sure there is.
Yeah.
It's,
it's the audience though,
is that other guy.
He need that audience.
If the audience is,
and now you could write a bunch of shit and go,
this stuff is,
this is the bomb,
this bit the bomb.
I mean you could do that and you can even let you shape it in front of an
audience.
You take it out and you owe them about that part.
It's there,
but it's like,
yeah,
I got to shave the end off of that.
The audience is almost your producer a little bit.
They are a producer because he like you
go on stage,
like you can go onstage like I've seen you like for the F do a new song that you
just recently did and it's already really great.
It's already there.
That's not possible with comedy.
It's not possible.
There'll be sparks and then they'd be dead spots and then it all needs to be
worked out.
Like every bit I've ever done has at least a dead spot somewhere that I have
chop out.
Like you find these areas where they don't get enough blood like is when he cut
it out and you pull it away and throw it away.
I feel like with music though,
if you could do a way you could,
your music is like more of a,
of a representation of you.
Like it's all like very little.
But comedy has like influence and influence,
not just like of other comics,
but I mean influence of the audience.
I like knowing that they have a different sense of humor than you or that they
have a different mind.
You need to have to introduce the ideas to them.
It's like a,
it's without them.
Like you cue you really,
it's,
it's a combination of you and them.
It really is.
You could do a whole song by yourself.
It's like when I hear your songs,
they're there ever last songs.
You know what I mean?
Like I hear you knowing you as a person,
I hear you through your songs.
That's a fascinating aspect of it,
man.
Yeah.
But at the same time,
what you're hoping for when you ranked that song is what I like to call,
what I like to shoot for is that what I call the highest common denominator,
you know,
and not the lowest common denominator.
Like the thing that we're all going to sit in gear and go like,
God damn man,
me too.
How the fuck did he know that about me?
Had No way did it.
How could it him?
Whoa man,
me too.
That's really what you're going for when you write a song,
write a joke,
your mate,
they're laughing cause they all have thought that same fucked up thought or for
any thought or something too.
And like they just now they're in the club and you're all in together.
You know what I mean?
And it's the same thing.
It's just I have to do all that and those dead spots,
I have to find them myself.
I don't,
I don't really have the benefit of like going like down the block and there
probably is a place I could do it but it just aesthetically doesn't work quite
the same.
Like here,
let me deliver this song and get some feedback.
It's different.
A joke is like about a laugh or an energy in the room right at that moment.
And if you didn't get it,
you're not there and you know a song can,
I can build into it and I can know if for me it's can I make myself cry or can I
impress myself with what's going on and do I can I sit through it right.
If I could sit through it cause I got a short attention span man.
I know what I mean.
And if it can keep my attention long enough for then,
then it's quality to me.
Well and feedback to is very different for music than it is for common because
it would comedy,
they say it's not funny.
Like that's sort of the,
it's funny or not funny.
But with music it's like you could like,
I could think something is fucking terrible but it's somebody else's favorite
shit ever.
Like to them they're like,
oh like hits their soul and I can be like,
Oh fucking Christ.
I guess that exists with comedy too.
But the word,
the way people describe it,
it's always funny or not funny.
Like,
oh that wasn't funny.
That wasn't funny.
I thought it was hilarious.
No that wasn't funny.
But when someone come up to you and describe your shit like to tell you what
they like and don't like about your song,
it's like that's completely a matter of taste.
Like you can't even say funny or not funny.
It's totally subjective taste completely so he can't get feedback from anybody
else.
Heavy metal guy does.
Doesn't want to hear it some fucking Pantera.
June.
Well you need to fucking bang.
I know you could Bang Bang.
The weirdest thing though is man in the audience I have is so bizarre because
that guy will be there.
There will be a guy there.
I can't terra guy,
there'll be a guy there with it.
I there was it last summer I did,
you know,
acoustic run of and I did wind up doing a few festivals.
I show up at one and I shit you not Joe Rogan is called Devil's slide or devil
side,
devil side festival.
It is nothing but the hardest.
Like [inaudible].
I'm sitting backstage with me and Brian,
the guy who came with me last time keyboard player and we're like,
what the fuck man,
this is what,
why am I here?
I don't even fucking get it,
man.
We're like freaking out.
We're like,
oh,
they're going to fucking kill us,
man.
They're going to kill us.
I called my manager,
I'm cursing him to high fucking heaven,
Dude.
Like you motherfucker.
You don't even look where you're booking me,
do you?
You just see a check number and you take it and you don't even ask where you
just say,
yeah,
we'll do it.
Huh?
I was like,
listen to where I am and I'm putting the
band after band of it,
man.
I'm,
I'm actually get to the point where it's like I just started embracing that
funniness of it and I told the promoters,
all right,
there's some things missing from my rider.
And they're like,
what?
I'm like,
I need to say Tannic Bible in a bucket,
a goat's blood right now.
I was like,
we need to make a sacrifice for we go out there cause we about to get killed.
And it was the craziest shit and you're pulling it up.
So,
uh,
I fucking,
I tell my boy w and it wasn't Brian Actually,
it was my boy Derek.
We were both playing two guitars.
So,
uh,
we go,
I go and I just tell him when we go out there,
I was like,
first thing to get thrown first,
anything,
we're fucking up,
I'm out of there.
And it fucking,
if someone jumps on stage and just hit him with the guitar,
man,
it's like dead ass.
I'm saying this dead seriously.
Like we're about to get killed,
right.
So this band that went on before us,
it was like the bread that gets buttered with bread or something.
It was,
that's literally,
it was some crazy name like that on the bread gets buttered or the butter on the
bread or something like that.
And it was the most hardest,
like
crazy.
That ends,
it ends and the lights and,
and this is the middle of the day,
by the way too.
This is like four o'clock,
maybe five o'clock and we're like,
aw man,
Jesus doesn't hide.
Come on.
The whole house clears.
So like all of a sudden I'm having a little bit of hope,
like,
okay,
maybe nobody will just be in here for our set.
Maybe they all just were like that,
no,
we're going to go get a beer.
So they are changing over the set and it comes to our turn and I'm like the
crowd starts coming back in and I'm like man,
this ugly.
Go out there.
And we started playing our guitars and next thing I know I see all of these
pants,
Hara and crazy metal dudes and they got chicks with them.
Now there's not a,
there's not a pit,
there's not pit.
There's all these views with their broads and they're holding their bras and
their listening and their blood and it goes over like fucking gangbusters.
I was like,
we and we,
we literally got offstage dump.
We didn't say words to each other.
We got in our van,
we didn't even set up merchant this place because we were like,
nobody cares where here we sold like probably a box of merge just out the back
of the van.
What people catching us cause we were just [inaudible] know Derek was sitting in
the back of the van just like,
did that just happen man?
That was,
that was one of the craziest gigs I've ever done in my life.
That's fascinating.
Did they just change gears like that and it was no other thing like that.
It was done.
It was,
it was.
I never,
I was just blown away about how it went and in the way it went over,
I was like,
wow,
dude,
that was crazy.
They really dug it.
That's a cool story.
That must have been a cool experience.
So my audience is crazy.
It'd be an old lady.
There'll be like kids,
there'll be,
you know,
the house of pain,
a roughneck Hula game.
Guys still hanging on for that to come back.
They're all still don't you still do an acoustic version of a jump around?
It's,
it's,
if the energy's in the area,
so the audience,
they,
I mean they got it as far right.
They don't have to ask for it.
They have to deserve it.
I you,
you must have loved it when Marcus,
David,
she used to come out to that shit.
Oh yeah.
God Damn Great.
Dana though told me he kind of pushed that into position.
Like not that dude resist it.
I think he had that for,
you know,
he had the two things I the beginning of the uh,
of that movie,
the Boon,
uh,
boondock saints saints.
Yeah.
That was like the intro of his thing and then,
and then like I think that was just his intro and then Dana says you should put
in jumper.
I believe that's either that or in a drunken party mode.
Danny,
Danny took credit for it.
I think it probably was,
I quite honestly
think it was Dana because I know he keeps people from changing the songs.
Like he wants like Uriah Faber comes out to California love every time,
you know,
and he wants to keep it that way.
Like going back to Cali,
he tried to come to come going back to Cali once with ll cool j and Daniel was
like,
no fucking way.
You got to go with California law that people expect that it is true.
Like I feel Uriah because I feel like a fighter should be able to change as his
walking music.
But when I hear the phone comes out,
yeah,
this is something pretty bad ass about that.
But a guy should be able to just a couple of guys,
like when they let those resilient,
like,
you know,
uh,
like a vandal that,
come on,
dude,
come on dude.
You've got to change up that music.
Quiet music though.
I hear you.
But that,
that pride,
that Electronica,
I'm like,
Whoa,
I don't like it.
My favorite [inaudible] used to come out like in dresses and shit and pride.
W O w well,
there's a guy who used to come out in,
in crazy dresses and k one the kickboxer Tude [inaudible] you lost.
Maybe that's what I'm thinking do I see awesome tip.
But you didn't come out.
They say,
Oh,
I know who you're talking about.
You talking about go,
no,
no.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Go on.
Oh yeah.
He used to dress up in a bunch of crazy,
well,
there's been a bunch of different guys from Japan that dressed up in wild ways,
tried to try to convince people these tension,
the UFC,
let them do that.
Greatest walking music though,
in my opinion is Matt Hughes Country Board can survive.
That was his song.
Yeah.
I mean this is the perfect song for him.
It's the perfect song.
And it was just something about stoic demeanor as he walked towards the cage
that that song would come on.
It's a good word.
That's a good one.
But one time I think Randy coture came out to Jimmy Hendrix doing the star
spangled banner.
That might've been the all time greatest.
You know,
Captain America comes out to Hendrix doing the star spangled banner spangled
banner.
It was one of those,
yeah,
there's been,
um,
what would your song be,
Joe,
if you had to choose Christina Aguilar.
Beautiful.
That's what I was gonna come out to if I fought Wesley snipes.
I'm not kidding.
Five Wesley's name.
Yeah.
I was going to come out to,
it's Christina Aguilera.
Remember when he had that,
is it ring at the same time?
Let's I click,
I wouldn't want to come out to some this,
it was a few years back before he went to jail.
Before he went to jail.
Yeah.
There was um,
this promoter who may be on Wednesday,
we're seeing if we could work on the podcast on Wednesday.
He was the guy who originally started the UFC.
His name's Campbell Mclaren and uh,
he is the guy who hired me to do the post fight interviews of the,
like in 1997 when I first started working for them and Campbell called me up one
day and told me that,
uh,
he,
had a proposition for me and he asked me if I wanted to fight Wesley Snipes on
paper view and uh,
they offered me a crazy amount of money and I said,
fuck yeah.
Or anything.
It was just you were going to fight?
Not at all.
If I could get away with not hurting him,
I would not hurt him.
I just grab a hold of them,
strangle them.
That was the plan.
The plan was to get the clinch where it was.
Did he have any arts?
He,
yeah,
he's definitely really good at karate.
He's definitely a really good kickboxer.
But as far as I know,
he didn't have any competition experience in his life.
I don't think you ever fought.
Probably could fight and he might've kicked my ass.
Who knows?
So it didn't come to fruition.
He needed a lot of money for taxes.
He was in a lot of trouble.
It wasn't,
it was never like when he watched,
he watched a couple youtube videos that you just tap it.
I'm sure that didn't help.
Or maybe you rolled with somebody if you've never rolled to some of the,
you try and like back then I was a brown belt.
But the difference between someone who's been doing Jujitsu for 10 years and
someone who just tries it out for the first time,
it feels like such an unsurmountable Shazzam that if he did just start it,
he'd be like,
Oh fuck this.
This is ridiculous.
You can't just do it.
And this guy's,
I mean,
I've been doing it for 15 years.
This guys that I roll with still to this day that just fucking strangle me,
just run right through me.
The rag doll you and you realize,
well,
if I had a fight,
one of these guys,
you're fucked.
Like there's certain guys you're not gonna be able to hold off.
And if you're a guy who's in his forties and you just learn to Jujitsu,
I think Wesley was,
that's,
you know,
you don't want to do that.
I was talking to you about that earlier.
I was,
I ain't going to lie to myself.
Well,
you know,
kick my ass and new care.
You got a healthy mind.
You've got to have a healthy mind.
People get crazy.
I can't tell you how many people have tried to convince me that they're
different.
Some dudes that have this,
they have this talk about their mentality.
You know,
they're talking about their mindset.
They want to like mad dog you and tell you how much different there are one
dude,
I talked to this dude for over an hour.
It was in in Belfast,
Northern Ireland,
and this motherfucker,
all I understand that he said was,
I'll fight any of mine.
That's the only words I understood how to ever fucking chocolate l I'm afraid I
saw Criteo how to fight any mine.
I'll tell y'all hot,
there's no quit in me.
And he was just going on and on and on and it's barely understandable.
Like every three or four words,
you'd be absolutely sure what he said.
Every other word was just subject to guesswork.
You,
you had to calculate like what could he have meant there?
What the fuck does that?
And then while you're calculating,
he's onto the next time I'm buying any land cause they fucking ass fucking
chocolate.
The other things is they're going to get in front of me.
I'll pipe in my hand getting,
I want to take same fucking shake from him.
And they think that they have it all in their head guy.
Dude,
they think they got it all in their head,
in their head.
They're just different and their head,
they're just so strong.
They're so in that too.
Is that to the,
you don't know,
Chuck Odell would put his fucking knuckles through your soul.
He will literally hit you in a way when he's nice.
He's scary.
Yeah.
He's always scary.
You know what I mean?
I've hung out with him many times like,
and just been like,
man,
any man you,
you could,
if you wanted to just beat up anybody in this room.
I've watched that guy during his prime from like 10 feet away,
fight the baddest motherfuckers in the UFC.
Those were some cause that dude,
like I don't,
I do not think that chocolate dao is the greatest fighter of all time.
I think he's one of the all time greats for sure.
But for me,
he was always the most exciting.
No one was more exciting.
Every fight was chaos.
Every fight was chuck Ladell waiting forward and just throwing missiles and
sometimes he lost and sometimes he won.
But that motherfucker went out on his shield to his very last five buys by
sword.
His last fight against rich Franklin,
he got knocked down because he was coming after Frankie because he thought he
had him hurt.
He just couldn't back off.
He couldn't back off.
It was just so crazy and so people to hide.
I'm fucking cat.
He's never met me.
Hey,
snap at athletic man May.
He doesn't go.
What I fucking gone through in my life.
I'll tell you what,
how fucking fight anything of mine.
I fight anyone any might have met that guy put him in front of me,
but for me,
they want to convince me and I'm like,
okay,
I believe you.
He looking for a shot.
He's just drunk and trying to convince me that he's not a victim and all you'd
all he could think of is just like what would happen.
Like if that guy actually did get his fight,
okay,
I'm going to give you $1,000 you fight him right now.
I'm not to fight him.
Come through this door.
You open the door.
No one had any idea.
No one told him we're just at a bar.
That would be a great reality.
Show.
A reality show that's connected to a bar and there's a door to the bar that only
opens up from the bar and only I can open it cause I have a key,
a key and I find the drunk is stupid.
It's asshole that wants to talk to me about Oh fucking foot.
I'll tell you what bro.
Fucking fucking fuck this fucking cave for the US guys.
Want to see this show?
No,
I've been around Mexicans,
man.
No know fucking I know how to kick Mexicans ashes.
And then they go [inaudible] dollars.
Right now you'd fight came,
bless his fuck.
Yeah Bitch.
I ain't scared of no one.
Write it.
Write it down right there.
I'll give you $1,000 right now.
Yo.
Yeah.
Well can we get to fight him?
I got $1,000 for you dude,
right now.
Oh there I write that.
Okay.
Come to this door like the guy has no idea.
You open up the door,
there's 8,000 people in a smaller arena and Cain Velasquez is sweaty and
bouncing up and down in the middle of the octagon is just stem pushing than
drunk guide.
Towards the cage.
Wa what the Fuck Man,
my own dad said,
what's going on here man?
This is a dream,
dude.
Am I dead?
Is this heaven?
The fuck happened,
Bro.
I want to see that show how to fight any man.
I'll find that guy.
It doesn't even have to be 8,000 people.
Cain Velasquez did.
It isn't even about the fight,
right?
The show is about the reaction to that guy seeing the guy he wants to eat was
said he would fight in the room.
Right.
Might even be darker if it was just Canaan.
Him,
you're here.
No one's Canaan.
Him and cameraman.
That's it.
Yeah.
I just,
thunderous beatings,
sundress,
beatings from a guy who never gets tired.
This some shit.
Like I had a war machine on the podcast.
We were talking about genetics and war machine was talking about how like
there's a reality of fighting,
like,
like you only can get so good.
You only have like a genetic potential and some dudes have genetic potential,
like to be champions like John Jones or Chris Weidman or what have you.
They have that genetic potential,
but there's other dudes that just know they're never going to get there.
No matter what they do.
No matter how hard they work,
they're never going to get there.
They're never going to get there.
And if you don't accept that shit,
if you don't figure that shit out,
you're going to take some beatings along the way.
And a guy like me or a guy like any pumping normal person like that doesn't have
like phenomenal genetics.
You're never going to be able to keep up with that motherfucker.
Cain Velasquez has like a triple size hard or some shit and like three times the
size of a normal lung.
Like when you look at the capacity of his endurance,
it's insanity.
It's totally natural.
According to his trainers,
I'm just making up the three times the size is,
he's built normal,
but his capacity for endurance,
like his vo two Max is insane.
It's like a super triathlon,
like one of those,
um,
uh,
ultra marathon runners or triathlon iron man guys.
Like that's what kind of heartbeat this guy's got as a fucking heavyweight.
So is it 240 pound man,
he just goes,
just goes,
runs down.
Everybody like no one can keep up with them.
No one can keep that guy's pace.
Who's he fighting next boy,
he's got soul shoulder surgery coming up or recovery from it coming up.
He's a,
he tore it in the,
uh,
somewhere during the junior dos Santos fight.
That's when I talked to like,
Bob Cook is man.
She was like,
he could take a month off,
comes back.
He's still at work.
Everybody.
It's like,
it's just,
he just has crazy natural endurance.
There's just some,
some people just have weird advantages over other people.
That last fight was almost not fun to watch a little bit.
It was unfun to watch.
Yeah.
You know,
and Jr let's say,
you know,
it's not like shooting in here to tell us that those is a mighty powerful man
himself.
He's a beat to see that get done to him twice.
Yeah.
And the same way and you know,
to attribute the first one to rob doe,
you know,
which is the,
is what they call a,
this is a disease that happens when you work out too hard.
A lot of crossfit people get robbed on my losis or some shit like that.
Um,
they said that he was diagnosed with that after the fight,
but my take is that that could've just been the fight itself,
trying to keep up with cane.
I mean they tested him after the fight.
I mean that was a fight for his life that he was essentially losing for 25
minutes and he had nothing left.
The only thing that saved him in that fight was really the fact that he had one
minute breaks in between each round.
Cause Cain didn't need those women at breaks.
He could just keep going.
It just can't keep up with that guy.
They have to got junior listed though is number one.
It's still number one in my opinion.
He's still number one.
It's like,
hey knocks everybody else the fuck out.
Do we want to see that fight again?
I do,
I do.
I want to give it,
I want to give you,
I think junior dos Santos is an undeniable champion.
He's a champion.
You know,
he just,
he might not ever be able to beat Cain Velasquez,
but I really feel and guys that are like nice guys,
especially a guy that you look and you're like,
that seems like a really nice guy.
He is very nice.
Like that was life in danger and like you're saying,
it's that,
but I agree with you,
but I want to see him try to figure it out.
I want to see them try to figure it out.
Look,
the bottom line is he knocked cane out cold in their first fight.
That's,
that's reality.
He hit him with a haymaker,
caught him,
dropped him,
finished him off.
That was a legit first round.
Tko for junior.
No,
you can't say that.
He couldn't do that again because he can do that again.
He didn't do that again in that next two fights.
But a guy like that because he's got that crazy power and because he's got that
mad mad dog fucking confidence that he has,
he really believes he's the baddest motherfucker on earth and you just got to
put his fist in your team.
That now though,
that's,
that's one of the big talking points when they've done a second time was like
after you take a beating like that,
it's like going to leave.
Yeah.
I don't think he believes it now,
but I think he has another,
a new goal to work towards.
You know,
I don't know if he'll ever beat that guy,
but I want to see him try,
man.
I want to see him try up until the point where it just looks like,
okay,
we gotta we gotta stop this.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
Crazy town close to being stopped in that fight and kept going.
He figured out a way to keep going.
There's a couple of times,
or herb dean was like,
moving in,
who's moving in?
You could tell he was thinking about stopping it and then he let them go.
Just heart man.
Yup.
Hard.
You couldn't pay me enough.
Well,
you know,
they were trying to set up junior an ouster,
but apparently our sir over,
he was hurting,
hurt his rib in his last fight.
That would have been a crazy fight.
I really want to see that.
That would've been good.
Yeah.
Junior is a sure it'll happen.
Well hopefully,
you know,
there's a lot of heavyweights,
that are,
that are coming up now to Travis Browne.
But the thing is the heavyweight division is,
it's so hard to get that good,
like,
and to,
to be that good world class in any other organization is almost impossible.
Like there's like very little heavyweight competition in Bella towards a few
pretty good guys and other organizations like nonexistent.
But so by the time an African Guy,
I'm,
I just started reading about the UFC is going to have come fighters and you'll
heavyweight,
there's African heavyweight dude,
he's a new guy.
Right.
I just read something the other day about this.
He's supposed to be a bad ass too.
They all look like bad asses until they get into the UFC.
You know,
they were writing about him like he was,
he,
you know,
he might be a legit,
uh,
he could be a man.
He couldn't,
didn't continue.
You know,
I would imagine that heavyweights from Africa would probably be pretty fucking
about us.
In order for your genes to survive in Africa and be that big or that big of a
person,
you're dealing with a pretty spectacular specimen.
I forget the name of the dude.
I saw it on one of them.
Not a white guy,
right?
I don't think so.
Cause there's a white guy that's some bad ass heavyweight
from Africa.
Yeah.
South African champ.
Ron Pots to a six fight contract.
That's a new one.
That's a,
maybe that's the one I saw.
He's a white dude,
I believe.
Yeah.
He's a,
he's a white dude.
Pam White,
African South African.
It's different,
right?
The Dutch people basically.
Right.
German,
Dutch,
like d outward.
Is that Dutch?
Yeah,
there South Africa.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
And they speak that kind of,
it almost sounds like the Dutch,
right?
Yeah,
that Afrikan I think it is like a blend of Dutch and a little German.
You got out that beautiful guitar man.
What is that thing called again?
Oh the the company that makes it is Leora Bay.
Their event.
I went up and met the guy cause I had one for years.
That was my favorite guitar and went up in us and met the Guy John Paul there a
vein.
It's a total family operation like he builds next is fun to do the bodies and
his wife does all the inlay work.
That inlay work as I spectacular they did is just for me with the shamrocks and
all that.
Is that abalone?
Yeah.
Yeah Dude.
And this Brazilian Rosewood like you can't even get it.
He just had a stockpile of it from years ago.
Like they stopped.
It was like illegal to import it after like yeah,
maybe a decade ago.
I have accused me of that of that shit.
You can't get it anymore.
Well cues you when most of the time when you get a cue that woulds like 20 years
old,
like a lot of,
if a real good guy like,
like gene ACU or show him one or one of those kinds,
they take their wood and they age it forever.
You want to make sure that all of the moisture is out of it.
Did they do that same kind of thing when they make guitars?
I'm sure cause he just like when I went up and toured his factory,
it's just all wood,
like he has a whole way,
like he was like,
I'm broke because alls I do is whenever I get money I go on,
I buy what it's like the legacy who that like he had a stack of this stuff and
uh,
the original one I had,
it had cracked right here,
the one I bought when I found it out in the world.
And,
uh,
I'd had,
it was my main guitar for 15 years and it cracked up here and I brought it with
me up there and he was looking at it and he was like,
Oh,
where did you get this?
And I was like,
why is that?
Cause it's Brazilian Rosewood.
He's like,
I didn't make a lot of these.
I'm like,
Whoa,
that's cool.
He was like,
yeah,
I can fix this and all that.
And he's,
he was touring me around his factory.
He got to the wood room and he was telling me about all the different kinds of
woods and he got to the little area where he was like,
I got 20 something sets left of this Brazilian Rosewood.
He's like,
and he named some,
I think some,
I want to say Brad Paisley or some famous like country musician like that,
that he just made one for.
And I was like,
well,
you know what,
not for nothing.
Not One so old and beat up.
I would love to have another,
you know what I mean?
And He,
and he kind of just said,
let's move on with the tour kind of thing.
And I was like,
oh shit,
he ain't never going to part with that.
Would,
you know what I mean?
That's cause he just got done telling me how rare and hard it is to get,
you can't even get it no more.
I was like,
all right,
it ain't gonna happen.
So he takes us on the tour of the whole place and um,
mind you in like 97 or 98,
I paid like five grand for the original guitar,
like in the market.
So you,
I went up there and uh,
you know,
a
whole tour ends and I'm once again style.
You know what,
I'm gonna be that guy.
I'm just going to throw it out there one more time.
I'd be like,
Yo,
I really would like to have one of those guitars.
And he's like,
I don't want to scare,
you know,
it's going to cost a lot of money.
So I'm already thinking 25 grand or something like that in my head,
you know?
And he told me a price that I was like,
Yo,
can I have to [inaudible] I was like,
and he was like,
I was like,
yeah.
He was like,
it was like,
okay.
He made me two of them.
Yeah.
Got to the Brazilian Rosewood and he made me two more in regular woods that I
could take on the actual road.
Like I won't take this on the road.
The road road Brazilian Rosewood has a very special hit to it.
Like for a pool cue,
like the way the construction of the forearm is one of the most important things
about a a pool cue.
And depending upon the wood,
they have a completely different hit.
Like a maple forum will have a way different hit than an ebony forum,
you know.
And my friend Eric who uh,
he has this company called sugar tree cues in his cues.
I just forward you a queue.
Pull the shit up.
Brian,
I just forwarded you this,
this image.
I was crazy.
We were talking about his come just setting up my pool table at the new house
again son.
Whenever you want to get robbed,
I'll come on over and show you.
We'll see if he'll drive that far.
I'll drive or I'll just pull the pool is actually said.
Not only that,
the pool is getting built right now my back yard is because I'm trying to build
my backyard because you know what my daughter's situation and whatnot that I
want to have to kind of back yard that all her friends are always going to want
to be at our house.
Oh,
that's cool.
Oh No,
we've got to play over there.
I tried to build that right now.
Yeah,
that's cool man.
I have that kind of situation.
He's going to take me a couple months to get my sticks sharp again.
Anyways,
so,
but I'll let you back.
I've got a crazy like this art dude,
it was this company called alchemy.
They knew they guy who owned it like I think he got caught out there on drugs or
something.
If I'm wrong,
I'm sorry,
but like they only made like three or four of these pool tables.
It's like,
it's out of steel beams.
Amazing looking like shit.
Two good companies.
Well there's a couple that are okay.
But the real companies for pool tables are diamond and,
and,
and I'm familiar Brunswick.
Yeah,
they had like all the slates and stuff that would,
this is like,
there's some other images that this,
uh,
this guys,
his cues,
you see it's all for him.
While I was going to say it's like they're,
it's about harmonics.
Like he says that the way Acu hits is,
it was probably very similar.
He said,
I don't make instruments,
musical instruments,
but I would imagine that every type of wood has a different sort of harmonic
look at the images,
these woods.
I mean,
this is so fucking beautiful.
And he liked those,
those guys that make these guitars.
This dude just collects this shit.
Like he'll call me up and he'll send me text messages of blocks of wood.
Like it's a girl's ass,
you know,
like you do to send you through.
They're like,
look at his ass.
I saw I'll even,
his sons were like,
Yo man,
they had to pop pops.
That's all he does is go out and buy wood.
Yeah,
look at this would man,
I mean that is fucking artwork.
That would would is nature's art.
I'm going to need one of those.
Beautiful.
That is and we'll make you one.
Yeah,
I'm gonna need one.
He's a good friend of mine and he's,
he's a cool motherfucker that that Q is God damn master.
Got to have the boss Q.
You know what I mean?
Everybody comes up with just the boss Q.
If you didn't bring your own and get one of those ones off to walled is the boss
Q,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
Shit,
I got a bunch of those I can store bought Mcdermott's and and all that.
Good.
I know they're good.
Planning Salad.
Mcdonald's.
That was beautiful.
That was like,
all right.
Yeah.
Well that's what it is.
It's much like a guitar.
Like can you buy a guitar like at a guitar store and it'll sound anywhere near
as good as that or is it an original one?
I found was in a guitar shop in Nashville.
You know what I mean?
It's just say,
you know what,
for me it's like guitars or like things that speak to me like when,
you know what I mean?
It's weird.
I'm sure there's something in your life.
Everybody hasn't been,
but it's like I walked into the shop that day.
I saw this one and it was the angel.
See I even had them replicate the angel on my,
on my original one because that's what originally I saw this work alone and I
just was like,
you know,
this is beautiful.
Let me play this guitar.
And it just,
the sound of it,
it's just so the wood,
is that what it is?
And I didn't realize it at the time because I didn't know it was Brazilian
Rosewood,
but it was like always been warmer to me and a little more,
had a little more bottom,
had a little more bass in it,
a little more ass than my other guitars.
I have other guitars I love,
but this one had just,
and he replicated it perfectly.
So is it about with them?
Is it about the thickness of the wood,
the age of the wood,
the density,
all those things probably,
you know,
and I didn't get it.
I just asked him to build it and I mean he,
I'm sure he told me sign it.
But I mean the thickness is all the same.
Pretty much the on this like the sheets of wood where all look pretty much like
they already wear the same amount of thickness,
but it's like,
you know,
it takes a while.
They have to shape,
you know,
this part is like,
cutting it out on the flat part is easy.
This is actually,
this was a flat piece of wood at one,
you know what I mean?
So they bend it with water,
something,
water and,
and time,
you know,
so it's a slow process.
Like I waited months for these guitars.
It wasn't Yay,
they're done.
It was like,
when they were done,
it was almost like,
oh,
I almost forgot I ordered those.
The same thing with,
with pool cues.
It's like the,
the wood needs a lot of time in order to like to shape it into something.
You can't just shape it.
It'll move and change.
Like you got to do it real slowly.
But the result is like,
there's something about wood that like it's the best for,
for certain things.
I know is the best for pool cues,
but it seems like for Acoustic Guitars too,
right?
They ever come up with anything that's better.
More clothes.
I'm sure there is,
but I'm also sure it probably sounds like garbage.
I mean the word is that it lives in there.
Its poorest and sound is like,
it's like I tell people the difference between like what I tried to do,
like even when I record this isn't,
you know,
for technique,
more technical people,
but like you know,
nowadays everything's done in the box and computers.
You know what I mean?
Like I like 10 I do 90% of what I do in the box.
I like to hit tape.
At some point you'd dump it onto a piece of tape left to take soapbox,
soak up the sound and let it become real.
Not some just ones and Zeros let it become like what it is.
Electricity,
you know?
Cause when it's in a computer it's really just ones and Zeros and it to me,
I can tell the difference like when you hit the tape,
even if you dump it back into the computer now it's,
it's been alive and that's kind of the same thing.
It's like,
I can't explain it,
but this was living materials.
It's porous,
it's got energy still.
You know what I mean?
A piece of carbon fiber doesn't really have any energy.
A piece of plastic.
It doesn't have that same cause.
You're not an electric guitar works because you're not counting on this to be
making the music when you're counting on the amplifier and,
and,
and your and,
and what you're doing up here is mostly doing the tonal work.
You know what I mean?
When you get an electric guitar,
is it the,
sounds like there's no like hollow opening inside of it.
There's some are,
I personally,
when I play electric I play grouches.
Like either white falcons are a country gentleman,
which are hollow bodies because then I can go,
because a lot of my songs blend electric and acoustic.
When I play live,
I can go with a clean tone on a hollow body.
Electric is not acoustic,
but it's,
it's close replication.
Huh.
And then when I go with it,
like you know,
in a distorted tone or something like that through a pedal and you know,
it doesn't matter.
So when you're making sound with an electric guitar,
like a flat,
like you know,
Jimi Hendrix style,
electric guitar,
where's the sound?
It's,
it's being processed inside the guitar.
Like it's without being plugged in,
it's not really making much noise.
Right.
It's making a minimal,
you can hear a guitar,
like you can play it,
it just won't ring out.
It won't have,
the amplification in here is coming from the box that's built around,
you know the hole right here.
The wooden box is the amplifier and that's what also keeps that sound
continuing.
The vibration that's strains and it's games revert back.
When you examine it keeps going like,
well,
it's still going.
Still going to sound inside the box just doing like this.
That's something we don't really think about too much.
You know?
He just started taking that just math we don't want to do,
you know what I mean?
I don't want to do that,
man.
That's real.
That's complicated math.
When you think about what it is though,
it's,
it's amazing.
Somebody figured out a way to make beautiful sounds come out of things that are
complete.
I'm an almost entirely at a nature up until the point where you plug it in,
but all that other stuff that's inside of it.
Up until then,
even the strings were uh,
nature in the old days because it would be cat gutter or something,
you know,
some old intestines of some animal get strung across it and tasty that Shit for
tennis rackets to right.
It was all cat guy,
right?
Yeah.
Did you know that?
You know,
it's like cats,
man.
They used to use actual cats.
I believe.
I used to think these actual cats and or I don't know.
That was always my interpretation of it.
I think that's really what it was.
Let's pull it up real quick.
Cat Guts strings going to be some gross images.
Yeah,
we get some things on that.
What are we going to make
the strings on this thing out of,
right?
Well,
there's lots of dead cats around which hair.
Okay,
look,
it's prepared from the natural fiber found in the walls of animal intestines.
Usually sheep or goat intestines are used,
but it's occasionally made from the intestines of cattle,
hogs,
horses,
mules or donkeys.
Huh?
So cat guy must be cattle gut maybe.
Yes.
Cattle Guy.
Exactly.
It says it's an abbreviation of the word cattle.
Got You.
Smart motherfucker.
God Damn ever lasts on the ball and common sense too.
But you'd hit it before ever.
It's that Alpha brain.
That's what
I should have brought some for you guys.
Every time I leave here,
you're like,
I'm going to send you some Alpha brain man.
I'll promise I'll have it.
Wait,
but though,
is that a ringing endorsement when you forget,
every time you tell me,
check it out for bread.
No,
it's terrible.
It's bad for the brand.
I get too much shit on my mind.
I'm busting balls.
No,
I really only told me.
That's why.
I know whatever I said I'll do,
I'll get it to you.
I promise.
So yeah it is.
But it's definitely cattled got it says alternative and may be derived from the
folk etymology,
the word kit meaning fiddle and having some point being confused with the word
kit for young cat.
Huh.
So there's like an origin of it.
So it was fiddle string at one point in time.
But that doesn't make any sense cause it's actually made from guts.
Stop being a pussy.
They're talking about guts folks.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I remember it.
I was always under the impression it was cat.
Good though.
Like cats.
Well it's funny that people would have an issue with that,
but the reality is,
I mean thinking about,
I mean cows,
no worries.
It's all good.
Saint no big deal.
What do they not use that?
What did they use that cal got four if they weren't using it for strings,
like what are they use it for.
Okay.
I Dunno.
It's probably a waste.
Vegans would not play guitar.
We could eliminate a lot of the folks things if we just went back to that shit.
I had a friend who was a Vegan who had to play pool with a leather tip.
He used to drive him fucking crazy.
There's no alternatives.
They've never figured out an alternative to leather for the a pool cue for
breaking the habit breaking.
You can't put English on a ball when you breaking.
Like when you believe these these like Gee,
10 tips.
It's like some really hard composite like foot phenolic type plastic thing,
but for like for an actual plan queue never figured out how to do anything
better than than natural leather.
I mean
it's weird.
I'm Vegan and all I get it,
you don't eat it,
whatever.
It's like Yo.
So do doesn't own a belt that's made anything or any kind of issue.
Product Hackathon,
understanding
as are my shoes,
they're made of compassion.
I mean I respect the effort.
I guess I just,
it's like,
to me it's like,
you know what,
there's an order.
I believe that as well.
There's an order and there's,
there's some,
we've talked the hunting talk before,
you know what I mean?
So it's like,
you know,
I respect the effort throwing of dude that would stand by it.
But if he's really all that about it,
you better stop playing pool buddy.
You better stop.
But when he eventually gave up on the veganism to,
okay,
I got to meat and fish,
that was the first thing cause I,
I'm might,
how long behind that was a steak.
It was not that far behind.
Once you've got that protein and system murder tastes better.
Yeah,
he,
uh,
sorry.
But we probably would have beat war and murder and all that.
A long time ago of murdered each didn't tastes so damn good.
He was never going to stop playing pool to,
he's a professional.
So there was a real issue with the Max Eberly's.
His name is a real issue with the tip thing can never find a,
an alternative.
I got them with fish.
He needed any Vegan.
I'm a fan of mine.
You only Vegan fans that don't have a good sense of humor.
Who gives a fuck which each,
it'd be nice for you though is the actual vegans.
I've only known in my life.
I'm most of them.
Like we'll walk in the room until he preached the Vegan thing to you with a
cigarette in their hand and maybe like a bag of heroin in their pocket
eating m and m's
talking to you about steak.
It's going to give you a heart attack.
Dude.
You should friend who was at cal video.
It'll make you happy.
Almost cry.
It's just as it that Farell song.
No it's,
it's just as good song.
It's just so catchy and we're talking about this before the podcast.
Say what it is.
It's this group of people that are trying to save cows cause when cows are like
used for like dairy and stuff like that,
they usually,
when they stopped producing milk,
they,
they are useless.
So they usually just slaughter them like the old cows.
And so this,
this group of people that have taken these cows and like,
uh,
like from donations allowed them to just like Diana field.
So they get,
they're releasing these cows that were originally supposed to be all slaughtered
like a hundred or 200 cows or whatever and instead of slaughtering and they
decided to let him go.
So these cows for their whole entire life almost have always been in these like
little cells and just kind of used for,
you know,
pumping milk and shit like that.
And so they,
when they release some though,
it's some of that like the most amazing saddest thing you'll ever see because
they are so happy.
They almost look like dogs being released from a pound.
And I here,
here's the,
I mean they start jumping around.
They're like waiting.
We're allowed to walk.
Wow.
That's so crazy.
Too Bad.
They're delicious.
I know.
I was just saying like that was like,
man,
am I going to feel bad after this now?
Yeah.
I mean where am I going to go right up the street and get me one of them
delicious.
Five guys burgers.
Oh five guys is so delicious.
They got this.
Like they,
they're even wiping their faces on the ground cause they're just like,
what crass.
I will say this though,
man,
like about as far as the animals and stuff that day,
keeping an animal like that deal for dairy purposes,
whatever,
and then just locking them in a cage for their entire life is,
I am not cool with that.
I don't think that's a cool thing.
I don't really,
I'm not really big on like milk as a product anyways.
You know,
I eat cheese and all that.
I ain't gonna Front,
but there's better ways to go about that stuff and there's better ways to go
about even slaughtering animals and,
and eight,
you know,
if you're going to be,
there's responsible ways,
you know,
and I try to,
do my best to be aware of where what I'm eating comes from because that is happy
to see.
I think they should all be treated like that,
but they shouldn't have been locked up for 20 years in the first place.
She could let him out once a month,
once a week.
You know what I mean?
Hey,
you,
hey,
you gave us 40 gallons of milk this week.
There you go.
Run for four hours.
You know,
and then that's just when we're,
we're getting a little bit too big for our own britches sometimes.
That's exactly what it is.
Too Big for the amount of resources that we need to,
to sustain us and too big to maintain,
you know,
some kind of hearts big enough to maintain.
We'll definitely too,
we're too focused on money when it comes to those situations where you want milk
and food and dairy and see why it's so much.
You're willing to let these animals get stacked in there like that for the rest
of their lives.
But a farm,
like we go over someone's farm and they have them just wandering around in a
field.
It doesn't seem so bad at all.
No.
I have a buddy in Wisconsin as a farm.
I mean,
I had like a philosophical argument the other day,
w w with a buddy about,
uh,
they had posted something on one of my pages,
like Twitter or Facebook or something about like,
you know,
we've got to stop the killing of dogs and Korea for food.
And I was like,
well,
you know what?
I find that repulsive.
But in Korea,
they eat dogs.
I mean,
it's like I'm not being racist or anything here.
I'm saying there's a tradition of in places where they eat dogs and it's like we
Coulson Indians find us repulsive for that.
They don't kill cows at all.
They didn't wander the streets and do whatever they desire in her life because
that's the highest station in life and on there on some of their belief systems,
you know what I mean?
So I was like,
you can't kind of do that.
You have to,
you know,
it's gotta make sense.
It's gotta make sense.
You know what if,
what if,
let's keep it real.
I'm a dog lover.
I would never eat a dog unless the Zombie apocalypse actually came and the
family was starving and those dogs were the only thing left.
They would get eaten.
I'm not lying.
But barring that,
I could never deal with it.
Like killing,
killing a dog and right.
But there's places in the world,
hey,
that's what they do.
I mean,
I,
I never,
I would've told you the same thing about kangaroo.
First Time I went to Australia,
I ate kangaroo like a motherfucker,
man.
So I can't say if you put me in Korea in the right place where it's a normal
thing and they said,
hey,
try this dog.
Right.
I would probably give it a try so I can't sign your petition.
Do you know what I mean?
I was like,
I can't.
Yeah,
you're saying cruelty.
That's a different thing.
I'm 100% with you.
Have you seen this thing that's going on with this giraffe?
I know you are because you post like raw slabs of meat on grills like every
couple days,
so we're cool.
Oh yeah.
I love animals,
but I love to eat them too.
Could you get a cow at your house?
Like for fresh milk?
Like wrong?
No.
You need to agriculture license.
You need a large parcel of land in order to do it humanely.
That'd be cool.
You couldn't just have a cow but a,
you might be able to pull off a goat.
But one of the things,
all right,
cheese I love and all this,
but like when my wife
was the one kind of started hitting me,
this is because I used to joke about using when she was breastfeeding,
you know,
using some breast milk for like my cereal or something.
And then you know,
she kind of turned around one day and she said,
well it would make more sense than milk because who really decided we should be
drinking off the teat of a cow because it's good for you that the reason why we
drink,
there's a protein in and out of people to say,
we'll say the opposite.
You know,
while they're,
well it's not the best thing for you,
but if it comes between starving and drinking milk and she had drank the milk,
it'll care.
We'd gone show.
Yes,
it is nutritious.
It really is the real problem with people.
There's a bunch of problems and one of the big ones is the sedentary lifestyle.
I mean we people that talk about cholesterol and animal fats and proteins and
how much of this is in your diet and that's in your diet.
All those things.
There's,
there's,
there's a certain amount of protein you need and anything more than that,
it's kind of wasteful and too much cholesterol is bad,
but not enough.
Cholesterol is bad too and not enough.
Protein is bad too.
Like one of the big problems with people is we don't fucking use our bodies.
So when you're,
you're,
you're pumping all this food in there and nothing happens,
it's just kicking the walls of your fat abdomen,
you know,
that's one of the main problems that people have.
It's a sedentary lifestyle issue.
Then you're also dealing with WHO's making this milk is at a farm with these
cows are roaming through healthy grass feed fields and you don't even have to
worry about using any sort of a homogenization process or pasteurization
process.
You could drink that milk raw because it's fresh coming right off the cow.
Well,
if you had that,
you'd probably be way better off and your body would probably digest it better.
Assuming a bunch of things.
The cows aren't infected,
there's no disease,
there's no issues.
Everything's been done correctly as far as maintaining their nutrition.
But if you did that,
I guarantee you if you're eating healthy,
raw milk,
people wouldn't have nearly as many health problems.
You're drinking dead stuff that's not supposed to exist in the wild.
It's not just the fact that you're drinking milk that comes from a cow and
you're a person.
It's also the fact that that thing is dead.
That is this protein,
calcium.
I follow you now what y'all then fucking he treated and shooting laser beams
through it and check.
That's not,
you're never supposed to get milk like that.
It doesn't exist.
So you just start farting and your,
your stomach starts rumbling and people go,
oh,
he's lactose intolerant.
You just drinking dead shit.
It's just how hard he is.
Your sister and then you replace it with like all these probiotics,
they're trying to sell you an out of took that's live shit.
The bad shit you just put in your gut and to enhance the environment,
the neighborhood of your stomach,
like people don't understand that when you're eating live cultures like yogurt
is just bacteria,
but it's important bacteria that acid off was bacteria is a really a strong,
healthy one,
so if he can get that stuff in your body,
it will actually help battle against some of the other more aggressive,
Eh,
negative bacteria and Candida.
It's that whole entire thing on that.
Does that,
does that,
did you watch the whole thing or do you know all about that?
It's,
well,
it's a long infomercials.
What it is,
I actually posted it up on Twitter and I didn't realize it was an infomercial to
the end,
but the facts and that infomercial or accurate,
it's incredible how much money has been spent in sure that people continue to
use sugar and high fructose corn syrup and how bad that stuff actually is for
you.
Sugar and corn syrup are fucking terrible for you and they're not just terrible
for you because it's,
it's almost like a toxin.
It's terrible for you because it feeds the unhealthy bacteria in your gut and it
encourages that,
that shit to grow and it can cause all sorts of like mental problems and
emotional problems and we're just not supposed to eat high fructose corn syrup.
That shit's not even supposed to exist.
You're supposed to get sugar from a fruit so it was like a peach.
It's delicious and it's sweet and it's natural and your body knows exactly what
to do with that shit.
But if you get corn syrup in your body,
your body is like,
what the fuck is this?
How are you getting so much sugar?
It's such a small package like what the fuck has 19 grams of sugar and a
tablespoon,
like nothing in nature doesn't even seem possible.
That info commercial was interesting because it showed how they got aspartame
passed and that was really scary cause like Rumsfeld was involved and all this
shit like that.
Totally true.
Rumsfeld is one of the guys who've got aspartame pass.
It's a fact.
You can look at it online,
you can follow the documents,
you can see the work that was done and all the lobbying.
Oh Jesus.
It's fucking,
they would,
they would take,
they take mice that got tumors from aspartame and cut out the tumors and just
say no,
it doesn't have any tumors.
Like they did all this bullshit fucking like,
like science to just to like pass it is evil white dudes at the top of the
ladder.
That's my next book.
So I,
I've been freaking out lately because I get,
I get like five splinters in this Trenta to ice coffee every day and my dad's
like,
you can't have Splenda anymore.
No more sponge.
Go with this shit man.
Steve.
Yeah.
And it's great.
It's great.
It's healthy.
It comes from a plant.
You don't even need a dash of it.
Isn't there like reports of even Stevia being,
there's like weird science behind it maybe,
but you got to look into that stuff because some of the reports that you get
like online,
especially like some of the reports that they were talking about in that little
piece on Candida talked about how the sugar lobby had come up with their own.
Yes.
Like Gavi.
Yeah they,
they,
they went after Gavi like with their own research,
their own fucking for gazy research.
Like it's hilarious how much fuckery is involved in our,
in our nutrition and our health and our start government itself.
It's all completely corrupt.
And that's just another example of it.
It's just the,
the reason why there is subsidies for corn,
it's like everyone's making mad crazy money.
That's why they just,
let's keep this party role went around recently about the subway bread.
But what about it?
And it had some crazy like
I believe it was like formaldehyde type substance in it to keep it so like,
cause you know,
bread,
the yeast and bread shouldn't rise after like a few days.
So while they freeze their bread and acute of this chemical,
like there's this thing that was going around.
My wife sent it to me again,
she's the person always into all of this kind of stuff and it was like about
this stuff and like how it broke down.
How like in Europe they don't have any of this stuff in their food.
They really don't like,
they have such harder restrictions and regulations on what goes into food over
there that it's always it.
It didn't dawn on me until the last couple of years.
Like why would I go there?
I eat in good restaurants.
Where are,
I don't eat the fast food anymore as little as humanly possible unless I'm
starving and I'm wearing as I got,
I have a cheeseburger,
you know?
So I was wondering why man,
I always feel clean and good when I come back from there.
Like a little bit different and it's because the food's better man.
The food's cleaner.
Yeah.
Not a lot of rampant use of antibiotics.
I can America,
not a lot of use of hormones,
but you know,
apparently the hormones are not an issue.
Like everybody's worried about hormones in meat.
They say that there's no evidence whatsoever that the hormones affect human
beings.
That's what I've read,
but what they do do is make their cows up to 25% larger or an average of 25%
larger.
So apparently they don't do it to chicken stock.
You know,
everybody thinks they do it.
The chickens,
chickens is actually just breathing.
They figured out a way to selectively breed them until they get the biggest
breasts and then apparently that's what they said,
that they don't give chickens hormones,
but they do give chickens antibiotics if they get sick and they only give the
cows antibiotics because the cows are actually getting sick from eating corn.
Apparently cows,
when they eat corn,
they can really develop like some serious stomach problems.
That's one of the reasons why they're so marbled is because they're dying.
It's like they're just so fat.
They just like,
their body just has no idea what to do with all that corn
farting.
I'll tell you,
the closest I get to be in a vegetarian is anytime I drive up to five by that
and by that one spot,
I know you're talking about the time.
It always is like,
man,
I know occasionally I eat some meat that comes from here.
I know.
I knew even if I try not to,
I know I had a restaurant or something and it's like,
and sometimes that just that the way they do it there,
you mean I don't,
I've never even seen it or witnessed it,
but I've smelt it and I know it's not good what they're doing up there and it
has the best.
One of the best steak restaurants is right technique right in the eye.
So I was like,
Shit.
Like right when you're going through that little shit area there's like,
where's this shit area I have about Bakersfield?
Let's say tap,
tap,
like around that area.
I don't want to know if it's actually task,
but it's around that area.
There's a good state Kratz around.
They know that they're just like going right out back and just fresh.
Don't tell,
you know my order,
we usually to steakhouses walk up by of fire and slap it in the ass.
You don't say that at that spot,
man.
They will take that.
Literally.
That's the closest I ever get it to
not being a vegetarian,
but being a Democrat is what I'm driving up that fucking five.
And I see when I was,
uh,
I was driving up there last time I was headed to San Francisco,
before,
uh,
before the elections.
It was like right before the,
uh,
the last election and there was all these crazy Mitt Romney probe Mitt Romney
signs and it was like,
oh my God,
you dumb mother fuckers are going to make me vote Democrat.
This she or you realize like how many people just the knee jerk automatically
vote conservative people like how fucking dumb some of them are when you see
their,
their campaign posters like you silly bitches.
You know that Kim Colt,
Mick chemical,
he was just talking about that since subway.
It's the same chemical used,
uh,
for uh,
making yoga mats
to what it was stretching.
Like stretchable.
Yeah.
That's fucking hilarious.
Like rubber.
Yeah.
Oh my God,
we're so gross.
We are.
We're really gross.
I Buy Ezekiel bread.
I don't eat much red anymore.
Worse is,
that was a mass thing that I,
I mean it got to me through like social media and met my wife texted me because
she saw it.
Right.
I'm not shocked.
You know what I mean?
But what,
what's it completely ignored?
People are still going to go right to subway and eat it and not even care.
Well,
if you want to have a bunch of kids working for you,
you've got to make everything real fucking simple.
You can't have them make their own dough.
Add the flour,
add the eggs.
They're gonna fuck that up.
You're going to have inconsistent amounts of,
but you got to give them the dough already made and tell him the press that,
press that button,
dummy.
See that?
Yeah,
that,
that's the means.
It's ready and then you pull it out.
Okay,
Neil,
fuck with it.
Like my wife told me that subway actually,
so they're going to take it out and I said yes.
As soon as they use the stockpile of bread.
They already,
as soon as y'all finished the poison we've already made,
we'll stop making that poison.
How can they say they're gonna take it out now?
Like you have to stick up for your guns.
You know you've been doing something real fucked up for a long time.
Look at this Yoga Mat.
Read this article is showing
five other ingredients that need to be removed immediately.
Like why is this in our food?
One is called El Sistema team,
something like that.
And it's mostly composed of deck feathers or human hair.
Did Mcdonald's Apple Pie.
It probably makes it delicious.
How come?
It's so Katie to ducks
breasts but not eat it's hair.
Who gives a fuck?
Silicone dioxide and Wendy's beef Chili,
which is actually pretty much just sand.
It's fucking Sam.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
A dime.
My thall pulled whatever fuck is in burger king and it's a natural beef flavor.
That's uh,
yeah.
Anyways,
I don't know what the fuck that is.
Yeah,
we're gross man.
What grows if we can make a little extra money,
we'll fucking,
we'll serve you anything bitch.
Chop that shit up.
You know bread's not supposed to last very long.
Like I Fred Day old bread is supposed to go to the homeless.
Exactly right.
Disrespect I'm saying,
but that was when I was young.
It was like the day old donuts in the day.
Old Bread.
That's what gets given away.
Like you know there's no good anymore.
You can't eat that anymore.
I don't need,
I'm pretty much gluten free.
I give myself cheat days every now and again,
but I,
I like to eat a zeal bread and those cheat days like and you can only get it for
you keep it for a couple days and my wife's always like,
wow,
this stuff goes bad so quick.
I'm like,
that's because it's good for you.
Tomatoes,
you get it.
Tomato,
they don't last very long man.
Once you pick them,
you got a few days.
Yeah,
that's what,
that's life.
That's what it's supposed to be.
This weirdness where a glass of milk can sit in your fucking frigerator for a
month and smell the same.
That's crazy.
That's supposed to smell like horrible shit.
Supposed to be sour as fuck a week.
Yeah.
If you're lucky,
nasty.
If you get that raw milk in three days,
it's smells like shit cause it's you.
You supposed to have already eaten and he's supposed to be milking that cow
every day or it's going to die.
That I want you to pull up that video of that guy in the giraffe debate because
this is a what's going on in Twitter,
right?
I don't know,
just pull up giraffe killed for lion meat.
Younger is this big,
big debate man.
Where this,
uh,
after this we'll let you bang that you were ready to go.
Oh No,
no.
I just,
I get comfortable.
That's over on,
it's a good way to over children and I always,
I don't speak into Mike enough either.
This,
um,
no,
you will,
you,
I like talking.
I love your songs,
but I love talking to you too,
so I get selfish.
I want to keep good dude.
I said,
God,
you know,
it was a rough week.
I explained to you.
So I'm cool.
I'm all saying something.
I'm still trying to figure it out.
I'm,
I'm thinking about it because of our,
a little talk about sort of experimentation with audiences and stuff and the
unknown.
I might pull out some songs that are,
that are unknown.
Beautiful.
Now this is what's fucked up about this.
They interviewed this dude,
I don't know,
this might not be the best video,
but they interviewed him,
the,
the zookeeper.
See if you could find a zookeeper,
uh,
like interview cause they,
they talked to him about it and they showed a bunch of kids this animal getting
killed,
not just uh,
getting killed but getting dismembered.
Apparently they did it all in full view of the school children and then answered
questions.
So the school children got to see this animal dissected and butchered and people
were freaking out that other zoos wanted to take this animal.
And why didn't they do that?
And the zookeeper was,
is this the animal?
I can't watch that.
Yeah.
They pump one into its,
its brain and then they're going to,
they're going to dissect it.
You don't have to show this online because I don't want people to,
that don't,
wouldn't want to watch it.
If you want to watch it,
you can find it.
The point is they did it as an anatomy lesson and let these kids see this is the
muscles of an animal.
This is what happens when an animal,
when you butcher this animal,
and this is what happens when you butcher cows.
And so the interview where [inaudible] was saying,
you know this American guy,
of course,
you know like why?
They're like,
well actually it was a British guy to British guy questioned him and he was
saying like,
isn't this cruel like what you're doing?
He's like,
well,
why is it any more cruel to do a do a cow?
You're feeding predators like these predators,
they eat meat.
The meat has to come from animals.
You can't feed a tiger like vegetables.
They eat meat.
So if you're going to keep a tiger in the zoo,
animals have to die to feed this thing like,
isn't it kind of hypocritical that you concerned about the life of a giraffe but
not concerned about the life of a cow?
One has to die in order for this animal to do you quantify?
Do you put one as more valuable than the other and it was just all emotions from
this guy and needs.
It's the non embracing of the food chain that they don't want to admit that in
order to make leather you have to kill a cow.
They don't want to admit that if a zebra dies,
you know,
and it gets fed to align.
There really is no different than a cow dying.
Really no different than killing a giraffe and feeding that to align.
It's just an animal that has to be sacrificed in order to keep this food chain
thing going,
you got one or two options.
You either led a Giraffe,
go inside the cage and just wash your hands of it.
I didn't do anything.
Or you kill it and do it quickly and humanely and then you feed it to the lion
because if you're going to keep a fucking lion,
you need some draft meat.
He needs some cow meat.
It needs some kind of meat,
but these could be,
they didn't want to admit it.
It was weird.
It was weird listening to the disconnect from this reporter who's,
I'm not a big fan of people that become reporters.
There's not really any reporters anymore,
man.
There's opinion takers and opinion givers,
They're reporting used to be getting a fact and delivering a fact and the
reasoning and the choosing of what it meant was to the audience that doesn't
really exist anymore.
This is also a political aspect to what they're doing because they're owned by a
corporation that owns political people.
It's that,
but it's also they want to make sure that they're on the most popular side.
Like when they're saying things when they're talking about things a lot of times
is not coming from a rational objective place.
It's coming from a place of representing an opinion that's going to get you the
most amount of support.
Oh,
Piers Morgan Syndrome.
Yeah,
there's definitely,
there's definitely some of that.
Right.
Representing an opinion that you think is going to be the most effective in
getting you more popular.
More people are going to be on your side.
Yeah.
And there's,
there's certain issues like that one where you really shouldn't be saying,
well,
isn't this,
isn't this horrible than shocking that you did this in front of these children?
You scarred them for life?
And he's like,
no,
why is it,
why is it bad?
This is natural.
This is nature.
It's showing these children nature.
And they had a lot of questions and you get to answer these questions,
like,
are we denying that this takes place?
Like what is the educational value of,
I don't know,
venting kits from,
the weird thing about it is like,
and just recently my daughter loves chicken,
you know what I mean?
And she kind of recently put together that a chicken she sees in a cartoon on a
show and the chicken she's eating or what's the deal?
And I had to kind of explain it to her,
like,
chickens,
we eat chickens.
People eat chickens because that's what they're nutritious for our body.
It was like a rough discussion.
It was like,
let me go to,
how do I tell a four year old that uh,
you know,
we're,
we're eating the chicken on the cartoon.
Right.
That's not the cartoon though.
That's the thing is that um,
this idea that we have of anthropomorphizing animals,
I think that's the expression with the use where you make an animal like a
person like Donald Duck or daffy duck or whatever the fuck it is that's talking.
And Elmer,
Elmer phone was actually a human right.
Bugs bunny,
all that shit.
It's like you're,
you're putting like human characteristics into an animal that we've been killing
and eating forever.
You're,
you're twisting up nature and when you're a little kid,
that shit is confusing as fuck.
Yeah.
Now my kids have chickens.
We have chickens,
we have 12 chickens.
Uh,
we just ordered more.
We're going to have more.
We have not,
we have 13 we had 14 and one of them I think a hawk.
Got It.
You think pretty sure as a hawk.
How'd he chase?
I don't know.
It might've been my dog,
but I think it was a hawk because there's no feathers.
It's hard to tell something happened anyway.
We still got 13 tickets.
My daughters know these chickens,
but they also eat chicken and so I have to explain to them,
you know,
like I don't have to explain to one of them because the fucking chicken bitter
in the face.
She'll kill that fucking chicken herself.
Chickens or stupid as shit man.
They will peck at your feet.
They'll peck
got attacked as a kid,
as a chicken.
That's how I got this scar in between my notes.
Oh,
chicken attack to you as a kid.
I was near a chicken nest and I've said it before in a podcast a long time ago.
But uh,
like I,
my mom wasn't watching me and all these chickens just jumped on me and just
start pecking me.
I remember just freaking out,
like fucking suck.
And I had like shit all over my face from pecs blood.
Yeah,
right here.
I mean he left out the part where his mom's sprinkled seed all over again.
[inaudible] I was supposed to be for the pigs.
I got attacked by a goat
little kid.
My Dad had a,
a um,
a Co op,
he was going to school and in San Francisco and they had set up as a farm co op
and they had a farm animals and they grew fruits and vegetables and everybody
would come by and they would,
you know,
the collect them.
It was in a school that they were doing this and he brought me with them and
this is fucking goat attacked me man.
And I was like,
I guess seven and the goats slammed into me but it in my chest and I'm trying to
hang on to this thing and to this day I will fuck up and go to,
we talk some shit.
I never forget that there's a lot of animals that it would take some shit from.
I would never take some shit from a goat if I thought that a goat was getting
crazy,
I would kick a goat right in the fucking face.
Fullback.
I don't like them.
How am go to at all to this day?
Because when I was six,
I could enter a seven.
I couldn't do a God damn thing about it and I never like,
he had to come and save me from this goat and if he wasn't near me,
I probably would've got really fucked up.
The female got involved too because I was petting the female.
The male came over and headbutted me,
but once the male jumped in in the female jumped into,
so,
oh,
I'd like to go back.
If goats lived to be like 40 years,
I would go back and beat the fuck out of that.
How old do they live with me?
I don't know.
Let's go have goat tonight,
dude.
Eat that.
Ooh,
that'd be a old nasty dry shoe goat.
She got a miniature pony.
A miniature pony.
They're cute.
Yeah.
And your kids would love that.
I don't think there are too bright either though.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
Well,
horses are weird,
man.
Like any animal that just stands there.
Like people say they love their horses and I totally get that.
I got,
I,
I've seen people,
I have friends that they like Callan,
his kid is in the horses,
like Talon.
Like he,
he's written horses to his wife,
rides horses.
They just sit there and they stand and they just wait for you.
Like they don't do much.
They eat grass and they said they can't be that smart.
There's just no way that that's mine.
And well that's a regular horse.
He's telling a mini or when he brought it down to being like this big,
I mean I can't imagine it's retained much.
Got ponies.
Well you know that was the thing about this,
this giraffe,
one of the reasons why they had to kill this giraffe was there's too much
inbreeding.
There's too much of the same genetics being passed around inside the zoo.
And I guess people offer to take care of the Giraffe,
but the a,
that's a miniature polling.
All my goodness.
That is adorable.
Look at that thing.
Is that a baby one?
I haven't been Burbank.
There's a lot of them in Burbank.
Everyone had like,
like walks him around like a dog.
Yeah.
That might be the cuter Shit I've ever seen.
And you could get them grow and grow it out and you know,
like kill it bites you.
And kicks you in the night.
Then I fucking archery practice in my backyard was horse tastes like I've had a
horse before.
I had a horse with a Dunkin and I had horse with Ari wants at the same place.
It's delicious.
Uh,
this is a place called Joe beef in Montreal.
If you are ever in Montreal
and it's a small place,
it is the most Jammin restaurant in the history of mankind.
God country.
Ah Damn.
That place is good.
And the dudes who run it are coolest.
Fuck these big ass bad motherfuckers from Montreal that are just,
well,
what is this Brian?
This isn't many horses like orgasm.
No,
no,
no.
Girls Get orgasms off horse.
They all just
turn this off.
It's not safe for work.
Was there a boundary,
a porn scene on that poor horse might kill your Dick for a week if you watched
it
now,
right?
Yeah,
whatever it was.
Get
she's leading her off to a mess.
Come follow me.
Let's work out all the problems we've developed in childhood.
It who's ass all the bread?
A horse down to some little fucking helpless thing.
God damn horses down there walk.
Well,
you could write ride the ones in Burbank.
They look like my little ponies and like these little kids right on in there.
They're just like princesses riding around Burbank or that girl is getting
kicked in the face.
This is what I predict.
I predict that horse
boxer and then one to the mug bitch
that has a weird animal man.
It's almost like a dog pig thing.
It doesn't really even look like a horse.
We're weird man.
You know what?
You can't domesticate zebras.
Yeah.
Tried and tried and tried.
CanNot ride a fucking zebra.
Zebras are not having it.
He can't go.
Nah,
I haven't even seen anybody try that.
We can't do it then I'd have it.
They're not hearing it.
Have you ever met a black guy that has
a Boston accent?
Yes.
Many.
So they exist.
Oh yeah.
Fuck yeah,
but they have a little black to it too.
What's it sound like?
I wouldn't want to,
you'd have to,
we should get a John Doomsday Howard on the podcast.
He's a MMA fighter out of Boston.
He's from,
I think he's from Dorchester.
Yeah,
they have a,
they say certain things,
uh,
but they don't have that had the Boston accent.
That is the,
the,
the White Irish Boston accent.
There's Italian Boston accent.
He's got to,
you know,
there's a little bit of like,
there's a little more slipperiness to the Italian Boston accent and then
there's,
I couldn't do the black impression.
I would need to like,
I don't want to be disrespectful and do some stereotypical black shit and then
try to throw some Boston talked to him.
I just want to hear it.
It sounds amazing.
[inaudible]
Unicorn.
It definitely exists.
No,
it's not a unicorn.
I remember the first time,
like I left America and went,
I went to London and like black people we're talking with English accents.
Kind of messed my mind up a little bit.
Just,
it just was so strange.
Do you remember Frank Bruno?
Frank Bruno.
The fighter?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Frank Bruno was like one of the most famous English heavyweights in America at
least.
And for sure he was fighting against Mike Tyson.
You want to talk about a dude who looked like he could never lose?
Pull up a picture of Frank Bruno.
Frank Bruno might've had the best physique in the history of the heavyweight
division.
Even better physique than Evander Holyfield.
I know that sounds crazy,
but the dude was just sculpted.
He really looked more like a bodybuilder than anything.
And Mike Tyson,
he fought Mike Tyson when Mike Tyson was Mike Tyson and Mike Tyson.
Mike Tyson was,
it went.
It went about the way everything went for people that fought.
Mike.
See,
if you get a,
there's a picture of his body where you'd get a better look at it.
He,
he be Tyson.
Beat the fuck out of him,
but he was just a fucking Goliath.
Dot Guides.
Perfect Physique.
Frank Brown.
Oh Man.
This is a picture of him right there.
There's one and there's one above it with Tyson knocking him through the ropes.
We could see right there.
We could see how built the motherfucker is.
The dude was just sculpted.
Huge,
broad shoulders.
But he fought Mike Tyson when he was evil.
Mike Tyson,
is this right?
This guy still around?
I haven't seen this guy.
I think he got a TV show from awhile back past the wall.
He was a judge.
He had a TV show after he does his show right now.
Judge,
Judge Mills.
No,
he was a real judge and then he became famous from doing boxing matches and then
he had like judgmental Wayne.
Yeah.
It was like one of those judge Judy show judge how much money I was his thing.
Judge fucking Judy Manx online more than anyone in the world like judge Judy
will buy and sell everyone in this room a billion times over.
That is rich as fuck on lots of millions.
Many millions upon millions.
Yeah,
like insane amounts of money.
Like she makes some mills lane was still around though.
He'd be doing UFC fights trust.
I bet he would.
While he's kind of older,
you don't want to get tackled when you get that old.
I got a certain age.
It's dangerous to be a referee because fighters not trying to hurt you,
but when you have to stop a fight,
shit happens for sure.
You know,
you're in the middle of a guy who's Landon haymakers trying to get a title shot
or defend his title or win a title and you've got to somehow or another get that
kind of stop and get in between them.
Especially if he can't see you.
If you're coming from behind him,
old dudes can't do it.
It's,
there's a lot of debate about women doing it.
Is the debate about women doing,
I think there's,
there's definitely women that are good at it.
Um,
but uh,
there's,
there's a,
a lot of a women that are MMA,
a referees one that I can think of in particular that I'll be kind and not bring
up 47 million per year.
Damn bed.
Um,
but you know,
she'll,
she'll have to referee a fight with a dude's are like light heavyweight men.
Does that just syndication money?
Is that what that is?
I don't know man.
It's a good question.
$47 million,
man.
She owns it.
She owns the show.
That's what I'm saying.
So she's getting that.
She's getting the commercial monies.
What's an act you get to show gets 200 million in ad revenue for CVS and only
costs 10 million a year.
That's incredible.
Yeah,
and she owns it,
so she makes in two years close to $100 million fucking Christ just to be mean
to beat bull.
You'll listen to me,
God,
that would encourage you to be just that much meaner.
Imagine what her given puss eat and instructions is like,
oh,
ah.
Stuart came in second place though.
25 to 30 million a year
pop out on the daily show.
Huh?
Well,
he probably owns a piece of coal Baer report to,
I hear about Tom Brokaw and that fucking cancer.
No,
he has bone marrow cancer,
which is like the world.
It's horrible.
Yeah.
Cut to Alex Jones.
The CIA doesn't want Tom Brokaw alive.
As they get older,
they get more dangerous because they have the information.
They know that the end is coming near and that's when the CIA takes them out.
If you look at those old guys,
they always die when they're old.
See he when they're old,
it's when they're dangerous.
They don't have anything to lose so they die.
They kill him to make it look like it's old age and they get them right before
they talk.
This is the reason.
What the fuck's his name?
Did a fake,
the moon landings.
A Kubrick,
Stanley Kubrick known working for NASA.
He was a Nasa Shill,
made the Moon landings that kill Sandy Kubik before he turns 72 backers.
Hilarious that they,
they all seem to dive in their bowl.
Well that's the thing.
They die when they're old but they know we were about to spill the beans.
I never,
I don't listen to do that much.
I'm going to have to listen to them more.
You've got to listen to it in real life.
If you had them in the studio with you will be a trip.
He would like him.
Alex Jones is a good dude.
No,
I had mind.
The things I've seen,
I've,
like I'm saying,
I haven't really watched like full on who has time for that stuff,
man.
I don't have time.
I'm happy when I get a Rogan podcast in,
you know what I mean?
Or an eldest show up for listening.
Pleasure.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
yeah,
there's um,
there's only certain amount of time in the day you can't spend.
When I was younger,
I indulged a lot more on doom and gloom shit,
but now I'm like,
listen man.
Now I'm like,
yeah,
I know the Illuminati they want.
You don't know what's going on.
I don't know what's going on.
You don't know what's going on and the guest,
what?
They don't even know what's going on because it's more than like one person or
one group that's affecting what's going on in this world.
They're not all in cahoots.
They're not all working together.
Stop it.
It's not that organized.
There's a chaotic whole movement going on right now and everyone's scrambling
for their own piece of the pie.
Everyone's scrambling to have a position of influence,
but the idea that one group above all others is in control of this whole thing.
That's not true.
There's a bunch of people that have big effects on it,
but this is a,
there's a social change movement that's going on in this world right now that
they will talk about in the future and it'll make the renaissance looked like a
fucking tea party.
This is going to make the 60s look like the 50s this is what's going on in
America in 2014 the world.
This is getting the world.
Absolutely.
This is going to change everything and it's happening in just a few decades has
happening over the period of just 2030 years.
The whole world is going to be completely different and no one can stop it.
We're not currently modality
just start popping off and we're going to be integrated with the technology and
all that craziness.
Yeah,
that Kurt's while Shit,
there's just started going over that again because of that NAM show recently I
went by there,
the booth of the company cars wireless struck up that conversation with a friend
of mine and was like,
man,
this dude I got to leave cause my mind's starting to go like all over the place.
He gets a lot of Shit,
man.
It's fascinating.
Listen to naysayers,
talk about Kurzweil.
That guy predicted so many things in,
invented so many things already.
He's been responsible for so many different inventions.
I mean the,
he's a,
he's a legit super genius.
Like I've,
I've had a chance to talk to a couple of dudes in my life where I knew that
like,
I,
I really shouldn't be allowed to talk to them.
Like I'm way too still actually be talking to them.
It's not fair.
And one of them was John Carmack who's the lead programmer for its software.
He made,
made quake,
he invented the,
uh,
like the original quake engine,
which is like this incredible three dimensional game engine.
And the other one was Kurzweil.
And that's Kurzweil started talking about the future and about what computers
will be able to do and the exponential growth of this technology and how it will
lead to artificial intelligence.
It'll be indistinguishable from organic intelligence.
And it wasn't a matter of whether or not it's going to happen.
It's just time.
People are going to keep this path going.
And I listened to him.
I was like,
I walked,
when we left his place,
it was me and the camera guy,
camera guys,
and my friend Todd,
who was the producer of my show.
And we just sat and looked at each other like,
fuck like what?
This guy,
just what is coming next man,
this guy just scared the fucking shit out of me.
Just thinking about the reality of you're in the presence of the one of the
world's genius inventors
and he's telling you what the fuck's going to happen.
And you're like,
he's,
I think he's right.
God dammit,
he's right.
Holy Shit here man.
There's a lot of crazy scary shit going on.
Unless the aliens land it's on.
It's just a matter of time.
I have a buddy,
I won't say his name,
please say,
isn't it?
No,
I can't cause uh,
what I'm going to tell you and you'll understand why like sitting in his
apartment the other day,
like God just chilling and he's real techie kind of guy and he pulls out his
computer and he's like,
watch this.
And he doesn't have internet in this place.
Any of this stuff.
He like hacked into every network around him and so the,
and this is just a dude who picked up a book,
he hasn't been learning in this,
are trying to hack for years,
picked up a book that told him by this one device and through that device how he
can just go about at night.
He can get anything you he wants from any way you can get your phone,
if you can get you anything like it like that.
And you know he's not bad guy.
He was just like,
is that crazy or what?
And like when I thought about it,
it was like everything in my life is on my phone or my computer.
I was like,
I got people at my wife how,
how many firewalls cannot put up in this.
And he was like,
you know,
it doesn't even matter.
I can get through them.
And I was just like,
wow dude.
It's like you really,
it's crazy.
You're you,
we are just living naked out there completely.
And it's going to get more and more naked too.
Oh yeah,
like the naked you,
you feel no,
this is the beginning of naked.
There's going to be no secrets anymore,
man.
It's going to be real hard.
But the intellectual property,
because there's gonna be a dude is rushing to put out an Everlast song.
You're going to have to make your shit and recorded on like fucking old wax like
those.
How did they use to do those old recordings was totally analog tape machines
still dude,
I still got tested.
Are you going to have to do,
you're going to have to do that and we'll go back to the eye.
The moment where you're going to release it because otherwise people,
if you have it on your hard drive,
some asshole's going to wake.
I know motherfuckers on awake at five in the morning that's,
we'll download a shit.
So you're snoozing away and he's downloading things for your computer.
You think your computers off and he's just leeching files off of it.
It's crazy,
man.
It's possible.
It's just,
it's all numbers like dude.
And my buddy told me,
he's like a week away from being able to do the thing where he can turn your
camera on without you knowing it and see on your,
in your house.
I wouldn't be surprised just like I just got to figure out,
but like he's like learning the language,
like you know the computer,
that actual whatever they call that,
where they used to call that language C to ostracize,
it's still called Dobbs.
That was one of them,
that kind of thing.
Whatever the modern one of that is,
he's like just all knee deep in it.
Yeah.
You remember when they used to have the dos window and windows that you could
pull it up and I enter in things.
I don't have that on computers and terminal on MACs in terms of,
that's what it's called.
So you could get in there and fuck around and do things every Mac is actually,
you could,
if you turn it off,
there's a way to turn it back on and it's a windows computer.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
You could do that.
I forgot.
I just learned that like not too long ago.
I was like word.
Yeah,
you just have to install windows on it and kept by a copy of windows,
a legit copy of windows because windows used to be that Mac was on a different
platform.
They had a different processor
and then they switched over to Intel these to have the IBM processors.
Right.
Isn't that what it was?
And then they switched over to Intel when IBM,
the the,
the platform could only take it so high in order to get like those three
gigabyte they had.
So they switched over.
It was a real crazy problem for a lot of people cause they had software that
only worked on the old macs.
That legacy software
you?
Well,
I had it for example,
like I had back in the early days,
I had pro tools,
the version of pro tools five and then all that pentium stuff started coming out
and like I had all these,
what they call cracked five
of like waves and all this stuff and like I didn't want to move into the next
thing for years because I just had this whole like $40,000 studio setup that was
working fine.
But like I couldn't really work with any other computers for a long time.
Can you
get a crack file?
Can you still download?
Like everyone's nodding.
Let's pretend they're nodding.
No,
no,
no.
You can't do that.
You can't do they know who never does it?
Brian,
Brian Red Band
actually,
you know they make it so much easier nowadays.
Like for like Photoshop,
you pay 20 $30 a month and you get every single one of their programs,
you know,
for free every month.
So it's like,
like you have premiere dollars a mile.
I think it was $39 a something.
I can't remember what it is.
But it's like before it used to be like,
you know,
Photoshop was like $1,400 or something like that and premiere was $1,000 but now
you just have like this monthly fee,
kind of like cable subscription and you just get all their programs.
I mean,
he's a lot more.
So second of all,
it's like when I bought that system,
it came like that.
The guy who built it for me just put all that stuff in there.
So it was like,
I mean,
but I mean I don't download movies,
music,
I don't know how to,
I don't know how to go to like a,
a torrent and do I just,
I used to,
I like,
I had an engineer.
That would be nice to see what he's done.
Government.
No,
I'm saying I wish I did.
I wish I did.
I would download a bunch of people are downloading mine.
You wouldn't.
I know you wouldn't.
A loyal ethical man.
It ain't hard,
dude.
It's pretty damn amazing.
But then,
you know,
if I did start doing it though,
I wouldn't complain when the music and the movies got shittier and Shittier and
Shittier.
That's true.
That's a good point man.
That's a good point.
There's a guy,
um,
on my,
uh,
one of my favorite message boards that posted a thread that he's,
he's uh,
a copyright criminal.
He apparently just downloaded some shit and you know,
just doing bit torn Shit and he downloaded one that was being tracked so they
got ahold of him.
I don't know the exact details of his story,
but he's just a regular dude who just has a regular job and he's going,
you know,
he's going through court right now.
I hate,
he owes a lot of money.
You're doing that,
Jane,
is that a movie thing?
Is it a movie thing?
Because the movie industry has done a lot better job of scaring people away from
doing it.
Then the music,
I remember the music industry for a second.
When it was first going on,
they had pinned all these kids down and like they were getting going to go to
jail and like hundreds of thousands of songs like there was like,
and then they all backed off because everybody's like,
oh,
they're kids in New Orleans.
It's like,
no,
their parents should have paid for that.
That's hundreds of thousands of dollars worth of music and work that people put
your lead cost.
Me,
if I make a cheat,
that Acoustic Gregory cost me 25 grand to make.
All right,
and that's cheap.
That's cheap.
That is so cool that you could do it all on your own.
You know what I mean?
That's another benefit to acoustic,
you know what I mean?
So it's like stealing that is stealing regardless.
You know what I mean?
I feel that way.
I'm like this though.
I won't front.
I have musically,
I would download a song and check it out.
If I like it though,
I will buy that fucking song.
I guarantee.
I think a lot of people do that.
A lot of people support.
I don't,
I don't mind that I,
I don't mind you.
I just,
why I was happy when they kind of gave people those much bigger listening
windows on iTunes because you can get a much like they used to give you like
that just little book or something and you'd be like,
all right,
that's the hook.
What about the rest of the songs?
So now you get,
you get a good like 30 seconds or something like that too.
You can really make a good call I think on whether you want a song or not.
Yeah,
that's big.
I liked that.
I liked that they have all your little even care and they said listen to the
whole song for free right now.
If you like it,
you can't leave here and listen to it again unless you buy it.
Right.
That's not a bad idea because a lot of the good songs you want to hear over and
over and over again,
sometimes a good song,
you don't need to appreciate the first time.
You're lucky.
You have to hear it like a second time and a third time to really know what the
is going on.
That's exactly,
I don't,
I don't mind.
That's the same thing.
That's why I wouldn't mind like a guy who honestly goes and I'm going to an
download the songs.
I mean,
I really like that song.
I'm going to go buy that.
Right.
Not only that,
usually if I like your song,
I'll buy your whole album in chance it,
you know what I mean?
That's my deal.
It's like,
oh,
that single was hard.
I liked that record.
I'm gonna buy that out.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm one of those dudes that gets into an album and I'll listen to nothing but
that album for like four or five weeks,
I just overplayed that shit in my car to the point where I'm listening to the
same songs over and over and over again,
which is so much different than how I feel about comedy.
Like comedy.
I can,
let's do it a couple,
two,
three times,
but then I'm done.
I don't want to hear the same beliefs for a while.
Put it down.
Look old,
some old school shit like old Richard Pryor,
I could still listened to,
but like live on the sunset strip comes on.
I can watch that anytime you're delirious
classics.
But some songs man,
like I,
I will listen to,
I remember the first time I heard a,
the ballot of Curtis Lowe,
the scattered song.
I must have listened to that song every day for a month.
I mean there's every fucking day I would get in my car.
Bam,
boom
to do,
do,
do.
That's a fucking beautiful song.
And that's a Leonard Skinner and song that most people aren't even aware of.
It's like one of the all time great songs.
Everybody always brings up sweet home Alabama and they call me the breeze.
All outstanding songs.
But God damn the ballot of Curtis.
Lowe's got some soul to it and it's a good one.
That song's got some beauty man.
This beauty to that song,
it's real.
It's alive.
You know?
That's,
and that's,
again,
that's a song with not a lot of shit going on.
It's just,
you know,
a guy singing and guitars and background shit.
But not too,
no the perfect
amount to good song,
the perfect amount.
Just like when you get Everlast and studio guitar.
But before it gets time I gotta I gotta say I gave it.
I,
you know,
I didn't come in last year and do this.
I did it the year before though.
It's coming up on that time of year when we're doing our,
our great strides walk.
So we're going to cystic fibrosis,
cystic fibrosis walk.
Um,
it's going to be in May,
but I,
I just tweeted out a link on my Twitter if you could retweet it right now.
Uh,
you know,
it's for our walk,
you guys,
Joe Rogan and my buddy Jason now,
unless you guys,
you're both of your audience stepped up so big last time when I had a fall and
um,
and,
and read cause I really only asked the two audiences.
I didn't really do much else and I think last time we got it up to about
$20,000.
That's awesome.
That's beautiful.
The walk.
That's great.
You know,
I'm also a,
I'm retweeted that right now,
ladies and gentlemen online.
It's done.
It's up there.
So go there.
Cystic fibrosis,
you know,
you can check it out.
It's pulmonary,
respiratory disease.
We've,
but we've been through it here,
you know,
my daughter suffers from it and um,
uh,
you know,
we're just looking to get it wiped off the books because they're close and uh,
it can be gone.
You can,
you know,
we can get this gone and I can be in here begging for money for something else.
Yeah.
And some other good costs,
you know what I mean?
Cause uh,
you know,
like I said,
the audiences have stepped up and,
and you know,
this,
you know,
besides just,
our friendship,
that's one of the reasons I always come back when I leave here.
I always,
you know,
get a lot of love and positive response and,
and,
and uh,
that's beautiful man.
A nice thing.
It's a nice thing.
I remember when I actually had quit Twitter and restarted my Twitter the first
time I came in,
I had no followers are like couple hundred.
I think it's,
I've tried like 40 something thousand.
Now I'm going to donate right now.
I'm doing even right now as you're playing,
look at that as you're planning.
Like I said,
we're going to try something.
Um,
this is actually something I wrote in Nashville with a couple of guys that I
don't know if it's ever going to come to fruition.
If anything,
I'm not sure if it's going to,
if it'll ever be on one of my records,
but I figured let's try something like that.
Do something new.
I don't even know what this court,
I think this is called a,
it ain't easy.
Hi.
With a zipper.
Scar from the stitches.
None.
No.
My hands with time
shy.
Getting other hand
honesty.
When know some kind of sad,
easy.
Sometimes I'm waiting this or house.
Oh,
we'll keep following
China.
Hey z.
Sometimes a witness the hardest.
Wow.
This bitch of frame
one Adam made me kinder.
Got a wish and a photo graph.
Warman made me laugh.
Word Adam Navajo go home.
Fine.
Steve.
Some town as a hot spot.
[inaudible]
you whole Wilkie found
hey z
Shannon and get a ride from their stock.
Sometimes the waiting is the hardest.
My new little more work on that one,
but please stop judging yourself,
which it was beautiful.
It's all you can do with a new song though,
is judge it.
You gotta just,
Oh,
is this good?
Am I working it?
Of course you do.
You have to.
It's like a joke you're working on.
Let me try it out here.
That's what I'm saying.
I want to do.
I'm spare,
moved out.
See what the feedback on it is.
You know,
I'd like to do it.
I liked it there so similar so I can understand it without knowing anything
about music I can kind of at least appreciate.
It was like,
you know,
I was wondering what I was going to do today.
You know what you do in that other song before?
I don't know if I've heard you do that before the uh,
yeah.
Did you do that?
Yeah.
Did you ever do that in studio?
I feel like,
did he do sex and candy?
No,
no,
no.
I know I did.
Do you want it done?
You want to know that song is my version of the songs.
By the way,
when I covered some of these songs,
I just,
I just Kinda do what I think it is.
That song was a song that I liked the first few times that it came out.
I thought it was interesting because I'd never heard a song like that,
but then,
um,
I kind of grew tired of it.
But you,
your version of it,
it's very different.
It's a little bit faster I think.
Well,
it's cooler.
It's a good song.
It's a very good song.
I like it.
A lot of songs when I often like warm myself up with,
so yeah.
But again,
this is my version and you know,
if I butcher it up,
y'all just going to have to dig it like that.
You know what I mean?
Hang now downtown,
Bam,
sue maggots was 10
thinking Bam.
Sue Nancy was double Cherry Pam and she was
this school suit fly last no six.
Ken
who was that Lounge and Ma Sha?
Who's that?
Kasey.
You a stills and not rich.
My,
when the show is a dream,
surely is a tree.
Hey now downtown.
Mama sue from [inaudible],
me.
[inaudible].
She was platform double Swede.
Nancy was back a disco lamb nee last no six then can they,
who's that?
Who's that casting duo steers in that rich.
How would the Charlotte is a dream
is a dream.
Last No.
Six.
Ken [inaudible]
who's that lounge chair who's at cast de Lille stills and my reaction following
the shoulder is a tree
is a tree.
Yeah.
Who is my spin?
Matt?
Sure.
I could understand the words in that.
Like there's a,
there's a bunch of the words in that other one where I don't know what the fuck.
Who was saying devious stairs in my direction now I know it's like beef eaters
cord in there somewhere.
I know.
I threw a really bad quarter though somewhere beautiful.
I kept it moving,
so hopefully it worked.
But a slang,
I smell six candy.
They're real slow and they do it to like a smell.
Samson candy.
Yeah.
That's real.
I think the guy who was
singing that song,
the original dude,
it's a great version,
but it's the version of a man is trying to get laid.
He's like,
he's trying to be sexy.
It's been a little sexy.
I fucked violence,
sex,
see song.
You don't need to try and be sexy with it.
That's why I like it so much.
That's fucking sexy song.
He imagined what snacks and candy would actually smell like though.
That'd be a fucking weird gummy bears and yeast infections.
I was thinking snickers bars,
bars,
bleach,
bleachy smell of loads.
Especially if you pull out,
squirt it all over.
Bleachy smell to it.
Yeah,
but he's gummy bears and or you might want to patent that one right there.
You want to move up to a better crowd as well?
Definitely stock up on rubbers.
Tell you why.
Because that shit is catchy.
Both gummy bears and eastern factions are both contagious.
Um,
I dunno,
I've ever done ends on the show ends.
Oh No.
What does it mean?
Anything?
So either this,
let's try that real quick.
We'll do one on one.
Um,
your mother
phd
now is Wayne Table Ran to paint companies,
downsize and then flees.
Math is feeling,
can't stress,
don't even feel the effects.
When he says,
and it's hands had been blessed so miles off track,
it's not smoking crack and once a his brain starts and chain me yet shirt off
his back shoes I was feeling was announced.
Team now is down stream now certain he lacked Jesse James trying to still go
kiss full.
They Watson,
she but even being in school,
nervous whether to bounce back in blood and poop.
Some people would wrap them follow
rats they snatch out one night
and Sam,
Sam kids getting murdered,
Cig name Salish and that struck when I,
when she was swinging at by lack Neisha and here polar wrap,
the men's,
they wrapped the flag.
You ran name wherein it's champagne.
Wait,
Jews on the neck,
last stash crib.
Ain't no savings now span to Landon.
She knew the bandit and stray machine.
Vanden smile.
Have to shopping sprees,
get an on knees,
hit the keys.
The old period you acting funny.
Come home one day by cam now to the wetlands out of Witty Palo.
The books you spin the rich,
she mad.
Swallow Paul
as
some people would rammed him.
Mother Rats,
they snitch on one and
Sam,
Sam kids,
cute and mood is
so far we go and my hands,
no,
it was making money on the black hills long.
Jack DMC,
they
disappear,
robbed him.
Mother Rats,
the snapshot.
Sam Sanchez get
super far.
We go
and then for,
I said,
I went home.
My has
wrapped their mother
rats.
This snapshot,
Sam's Kids Mood for him.
Glorious.
Absolutely glorious.
Uh,
yeah,
I never heard that acoustic version four.
I don't think I pulled it out a lot because
that mid section where I go to,
I feel like it just loses something when I go to the,
the bridge without like an accompany us.
But it sounded all right right there.
It's weird,
you know,
because you've got all these things going on your mind when it's just you and a
guitar.
You know,
like when you got a band to lean on,
it's like you can fuck up a little bit more.
You know,
there's no guy,
Eric Clapton throws an occasional brick on stage,
you know,
I mean,
but you don't know it because he's a master and because he's got masters around
him.
You know.
That's interesting.
I never even,
I throw a lot more breaks than that.
I build houses on stage.
I never even thought about that.
But yeah,
that must,
when you have a bunch of people also playing the same,
it's harder to catch up.
Think about your jokes,
when you,
how many times do you stumbling into it a different way every night?
You know,
it's never exactly the same.
The rhythm changes cause you got your dealing with elements.
So when you were on stage,
do you ever like free ball?
Do you ever in the middle of a song you just decide to like riff a little bit?
Um,
not really because,
you know,
I'm,
I'm the,
I'm a song writer so I'm a,
I want to say a slave to my songs,
but egotistically I'm a slave to my songs.
I live with my songs and,
but I mean,
I,
I always encourage my guys when I'm playing with a full band to stay true to my
song,
but live and breathe in it,
you know,
in other words,
go ahead.
If you feel it a little here,
a little there,
and it's going to compliment and you know,
don't,
you know,
I'm not a nut about like that lick you pulled on the third bar of second
section.
You know,
it's not like that.
As long as it's rock and roll,
it's not Beethoven.
You know what I mean?
He smashed his lungs were all partying and having fun and everybody's feeling
it.
That's what,
what,
what you're going for.
You study old classical shit like Beethoven or I wouldn't call it study.
Listen,
yeah.
Listen for ideas and you know,
things,
it all stems from that.
You know what I mean?
I wouldn't call myself a a,
you know,
uh,
a master of the knowledge of the history of music or anything.
But I,
you know,
I try to,
know where the roots,
I mean all rock and hold the blues.
Everything's kind of stems from that era of all that classical writing and then
a mixture of like when slaves and came to America with that and Gospel and you
know,
and,
and classical all kind of formed and then you turned into jazz and rock and roll
and everything since and Blues Blues came here.
Right?
It was,
it was some blues,
Blues,
blues to my knowledge,
Blues is American.
Yeah.
Isn't is an American thing is built out of exactly what I'm saying.
This,
that,
the era of this,
of of the slave times and then and,
and the,
and the period right thereafter,
you know what I mean?
Um,
it was the combination of field songs and church music and you know,
this learning of other musics too,
but like that's basically where the blues comes from.
It's interesting.
I wonder what it must be like.
The,
and everything since comes from that,
from the blues,
Blues and Jazz,
the pain and suffering of the slaves,
and then had to be there,
the origins of it.
Right.
I mean,
if you would have to imagine there's a lot of,
you know,
beautiful music and stuff that definitely came out of that.
Yeah.
Right.
I mean,
I mean it's like,
you know,
I,
in my personally in no way comparing my pain in life to slave pain back in days,
but I'm saying my experience in writing is my better stuff.
Even songs that are happier songs I write when I'm not feeling that happy.
You know what I mean?
Which is like,
if you're saying there's a lot of joyful slave songs,
you know what I mean?
That it gets sung and it's because,
you know,
I would imagine it's so dark as it is.
You don't need another dark song.
Cause let's take that darkness and turn it on its ass.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Find a way to find joy and turn it upside down.
Hey kids lessons from,
Gee Everlast yeah,
I'm just,
I'm still taking lessons,
man.
You ever tried to put yourself back in the Beethoven days and imagine would have
been like trying to create music back then?
I don't know if I would've been able to live long enough to tolerate some of the
smells that probably existed back then.
Dude.
I just don't even think his ass like,
you know,
like when I watched those old shows and I just said,
it's weird that my mind goes places like this.
I used to rest that HBO show Rome and there was like an episode that literally
where they went like to the outdoor shitters having a conversation together and
like wipe their ass with like what looked like leather cloths.
And I was just like,
how awful this like sto cities must have dunk like of just human disgusting
feces and nest.
Well,
I mean even the rich people must have stunk to high heaven,
man.
Yeah,
everybody is stuck.
I couldn't imagine what the streets must have smelled like.
I mean,
didn't they have an issue with that?
Have you know what,
you've been to Venice,
right?
No,
never been to Venice,
Venice,
California,
no.
Venice,
Italy.
You can kind of get a gist if you go to Venice.
I'm sorry,
I stepped up to Mike to put this down without it falling
case can fall,
not the guitar.
Um,
uh,
but in Venice,
like every other third,
fourth canal you rock by as like a sewage canal and it's like it's badly third
or forth.
It seemed like that to me,
I could be wrong,
but there's quite a few like you back,
you know,
they're not the main walkways,
but when you cut through a couple of main walkways you'll,
you'll walk through like these things that seem to be sewer canals and less and
less the day I was there,
it was just a really bad day for them.
But I think they were sewer canals.
But it's like you can kind of get like,
wow,
every street probably smelled like this way back in the day in Rome and here and
imagine New York and like the 18 hundreds,
man.
Oh yeah.
Like imagining that gang in New York days smell now is,
is like imagine it then like on the five corners were the whole gangs in New
York.
Shit was going on.
All that,
just dead bodies in the street.
Yeah.
That gangs in New York Shit was pretty wild.
It's hard to imagine that that was really going on back then that day.
You know,
we think of New York has always been like a normal city,
but ruthless violence back then ruthless.
So the water systems of imperial war,
Rome,
they had like this whole,
uh,
this whole system of a,
of getting rid of their waste,
but they did a terrible job of it.
People got sick.
Fuck,
I mean better than probably you or I would have figured out,
but
many ways it was the highest point of sewage management.
That's really interesting.
And other public works in the ancient world,
famous for public baths in latrines with quite complex engineering.
Rome also excelled,
excelled in the use of covered drains for storm water and sewage with some
houses connected directly to the drainage system.
So if you're rich,
you get shit in that river hole.
He had a whole and just drop a Dukie and a flow away.
Wow.
Yeah.
They tried.
They tried to figure it out.
Even if they were the best added at the time,
it probably still was one of the worst smells ever.
Well,
think about how long Rome was around too.
I mean,
how long was roam around before shit went bad and the calcium fell apart and it
became what it is now.
I mean,
the Rome,
Rome,
the old days,
the coliseum run,
we think of wrong.
We think of the Roman empire like no,
they probably rocked it for several hundred years,
you know,
many,
many years.
I think that a good 500 year run,
maybe let's find out.
I would say maybe a thousand.
How long was the Roman Empire?
How long?
I thought that's kind of where the saying there is no thousand your empire came
from.
You might,
maybe it was just short of a thousand.
Maybe that's why I paused.
I could be way off.
It seems like plausible Rome,
you know,
when you think about our history and how many,
yeah,
stages of it.
Rome played into the,
yeah,
well definitely a few hundred years.
Right.
But if you look at it like United States,
we've had a pretty good God.
Damn you are working on to 50.
Yeah.
And from the time we were really running shaman a thousand is plausible.
I just automatically in my brain I know that saying and I was like,
maybe that's why that's there.
This is too hard to figure out while also doing a podcast,
but it looks like several hundred at at the very least.
It's hard to,
it's hard to tell how many Caesar's,
you know,
a gang of these mother fuckers.
You know,
that's one of the things that I love about uh,
this uh,
game of Thrones show as you really get a chance to say,
besides all the fantasy stuff and dragons and shit,
you really get a chance to see what it must've been like back then when there
were real kings that actually fucked and killed pink bowl.
And the
fact that kings were also not,
they weren't kings of countries.
They were like basically like kings counties.
When you look at it like they had their spot and they had all the land around
them and they,
those people work for them on their land and they took care of those people and
that's,
they were the king of those people.
The king in the north.
So like,
you know,
they could be like the king of Van Eyes and the king of Woodland Hills King of
receipts.
Especially when you're on horses,
right?
You could be king of thousand oaks.
It's just too far.
Where are you going to get it?
All the way up to thousand oaks run shit,
come on.
So I was already a king in thousand oaks.
Don't you know that if there's any king out there is going to go to bat with the
King of Auction Oxnard King of auction artist Piss
the king of thousand oaks.
You don't fuck with that.
Simi Valley King Man King,
their ranch king's it live as King Arthur May.
No kings were like just dirty mother landlords,
man.
That's all they were.
It was fucking apartment like slum lord owners.
That's what kings were mostly for the most part.
Well,
you could usurp it king too,
right?
You could like,
that's the whole thing about Conan the barbarian.
I think that's all that goes on and on.
Game of Thrones is the usurping of kings that Conan the barbarian shit was all
about you.
Surfing is all about this book or something was called cone and the usurper.
Exactly.
One of the,
one of the first books.
Yeah.
Books.
We're talking books,
man.
We're not talking about movies.
Robert E.
Howard.
Folks,
you want to talk about a tortured dude.
There was a,
that was a tortured dude wind up blowing his fucking brains out.
Just a live with his mom,
I think to the day he died.
He was in his thirties massively depressed.
It was like I'm Outta here.
Boom.
At Kone and was probably this whole universe.
Well,
the writing of Conan,
certainly what?
I mean,
he,
he had a lot of health issues that dude,
and I think,
you know,
he really romanticized and felt connected to this idea of this unbelievably veer
aisle and Alpha fucking Predator man.
We're cut his path through this ancient world with a sword and fucking stood up
to sorcerers his shit and cut their fucking [inaudible] exactly.
I wanted to be in and when he knew it wasn't happening,
he's like,
all right,
I wrote enough,
boom,
see ya.
Hey man,
you know some people,
you know,
it's weird.
It's like sometimes we look on that is like tragic,
but then like you look at it like I was watching the um,
uh,
buy a ticket,
take the ride the other day I was just about to add it up and a,
and how like we,
you know,
so much,
it's so tragic.
But like for somehow,
you know,
we look at,
at,
at hunter and we say like,
you know,
when he made his choice,
man,
and that's what his choice was,
you know,
and he lived a long life and it's like,
why?
Why can't that guy,
I haven't been there.
Why hasn't he white your,
hey,
why does it have to be try?
Maybe he just decided,
yeah,
it's from the livings perspective.
I understand why we all look at it that way.
Like,
oh no,
that's the last thing we ever want,
but hey,
maybe that guy,
you're right.
Maybe he just said like,
you know what,
I'm never going to be fucking Conan.
Yeah.
And just was like,
you know,
and if he,
I'm not aware of his story,
but if he was health problems they had was written with health problems and all
that stuff.
Hey fuck yeah man.
I'm a I,
I think doctor working and was a hero.
I'm one of those guys.
I'm with you.
I think people,
if people are suffering,
especially if people are in the last days of life,
there's nothing can bring them back.
I mean in most countries in the world have not,
most countries,
but many,
many advanced countries have doctors that can do things like that and they can
help people.
Am I talking on my ass?
I believe that's true.
I think assisted suicide is more common in other parts of the world.
Watched her.
I watched a thing on it.
Assisted suicide throughout the world.
Okay.
It was a crazy little two man thing.
I think it came from a place,
it was on Hbo.
It was Samuel L.
Jackson.
Uh,
my wife just texted me.
Email is blowing up with donations.
Tell Jack.
Thank you for it.
Yeah,
I
thank all of you.
Not just Joe.
Thank all of you.
All of you.
You don't know.
I mean I can't,
I can never,
as a parent of a,
of a child with cystic fibrosis,
I can never express the gratitude that's in my heart for what,
what everybody has done.
Sophie,
even up to now,
if nobody did anything.
Again,
people who have stepped up in ways that I never imagined in my life and,
and the strangers and friends.
So thanks to all of you.
I've,
it's changed me as a person.
It made me look at things differently when a more grateful sense of life and
when you can get caught up,
when you have a child with these kind of problems in a,
in a very,
you can easily get caught in a downward spiral and you know what I mean?
And people are what keep you out of that beautiful mine.
It is.
It is nice when you find out that the world isn't just filled with shit heads
there and I,
it really isn't and but they want to convince us all that it is.
You know,
just like they want us all to be afraid of the guy with the gun outside.
every time you turn on the news it's the same with like people are good,
people want to be good for the most part.
I believe that and I always will.
There's a lot of them,
that's for sure.
Are there a lot of assholes to,
sure,
sure.
But you know that Joe Rogan and his and his peoples have shown me that there's a
better way to react to those people.
There's a way that you can get through this life where you have the least amount
of conflict and that's the way that you should choose.
And I've,
I've done both.
I've been involved in a lot of conflicts and I've been involved in a little
conflict and the little is way better,
way better.
It's way,
way easier to get mine.
Usually you get old enough,
you figure that out.
It's also,
you realize like how you become more sensitive to how bad it feels when you do
get involved in conflict,
that you could have avoided that,
that feeling of having done something stupid and avoidable,
that gnawing feeling in the back of your brain,
that's not a good feeling to have.
Not at all.
And then there's the occasion when you may hurt somebody or whether it be
physically,
mentally,
whatever.
You know,
I have it as much as big of a dick as I've been in my life at times.
I'd have this big heart that has a lot of,
I can feel even for a guy I hate,
I can feel,
you know what I mean?
Like,
Oh man,
that's a,
I still wish I didn't punch him in his face or it didn't do that.
Whatever that was.
And I mean,
so I know what you mean.
You know,
the older I get,
the more the kids did a lot of that for me to,
you know,
seeing like,
um,
minor things happen where I'd get a little upset and see how it would affect my
child.
Like,
oh my God,
I can't let this affect my child.
You know what,
I got to learn how to,
to process things differently.
And that's a big difference in the amount of patients that you need when you
raise the child.
And the way I also started looking at everybody as a baby.
That's the one of the weird things that happened when I started raising babies
from a baby to a person.
I'd met babies before,
but I'd never been there from the jump.
You know,
I never seen the whole process.
And when you see the whole process,
there's some weird recognition that happened in my brain where everyone that I
saw everywhere in life,
what no matter how fucked up they are.
And no matter how I recognize them as an originally a baby,
like homeless people freaked me out because of that.
It doesn't necessarily freak
me out because,
uh,
you know,
I feel like I should save them or I,
I accept their fate.
I,
you know,
accept the fact there's just too many people to,
to fix.
But I also see them as babies.
I see them as babies that just got a shit roll the dice,
terrible parents,
bad circumstance,
and then everything else that comes after that,
which led them to this position,
whether it's insanity or whether it's a drug addiction or whatever the fuck it
is,
crying,
whatever it is that brought them to the place where you find them now they
started out as babies.
That's a real mind fuck.
And when I,
when I applied that mind fuck to human beings,
I have way more compassionate to people or force going to be stuck in my head
now.
It really changed my world,
man changed my world.
I really did,
really was a paradigm shift.
I mean,
it's not that I'm always completely consistent with it.
You know,
I think all of us are dealing with a bunch of different pressures and stresses
and you can catch someone one day like I have,
I have friends that are like always jovial and great to be around and he catch
dude the wrong day and everything is just short and can't handle this and just
fucking,
I gotta get Outta here.
And then you see him the next day.
Oh sorry about yesterday man.
I,
you know,
I'm fucking,
I just quit smoke cigarettes or I lost my dog,
or whatever it is.
You catch them in that bad spot where they're just got this.
But for the most part,
I think we,
we,
we're,
we're dealing with people today that know the benefits of being nice more than
anybody that's ever known it more than anybody ever.
Because the only people that you had in your life like a hundred years ago where
the people that were in your life physically,
there was very few representations of,
of life outside of the people that you got in contact with.
You can read some books,
but you really couldn't talk to those dudes.
You can kind of get a sense of how they were living their life.
But what did you see in front of you?
Well,
that's what you're going to base your shit on.
Not Today,
man.
I today,
today it's a totally different world today.
A dude could listen to Everlast talk on a podcast about life and then
contemplate that shit for the rest of his day and then tomorrow wake up with
this new way of looking at the world because they've just been thinking about
something that you said that like,
God dammit,
he's got a fucking point.
If I just did that,
maybe I would be happier if I just did that.
Maybe life would be better if I just did that.
Maybe I would get a better handle on who the fuck I am and that's never existed
before.
It's never been possible before.
That happened for me here.
One of the few things,
one,
I want raise,
I dig talking to you and hanging out with you so much cause I get that happens
to me here.
I'd say at least every other time I'll leave here with something.
We may not be earth shattering,
life changing,
but it will be something that I'll be able to chew on for a while.
You know what I mean?
Well,
that's what we get those,
we get those from talking to each other and we get those from people that we
also know our thinking about shit.
Like you're thinking about shit live in as you,
I'm thinking about shit living as me.
We come together and then you,
you say something like,
Oh okay,
I see what it just motherfuckers calling from.
Oh yeah.
Wow.
And then you know,
maybe you'll influence something that uh,
you know,
add to an idea that I had had or add to a thought that I was working on and then
someone else to come in next week and they'll say something crazy to,
and then that adds to it too.
And then you repeat it on the podcast and people start tweeting it and then it
becomes a thought that gets shared with who knows how many people thought
hundreds of thousands.
It's crazy.
It's almost just really had a vision of like the entire human race as a brain
and that being that what you're saying being like a thought,
starting to travel through it,
what kind of is in a lot of ways,
I mean it's,
it's not not a brain necessarily,
but a system,
an organized system of thinking.
That's what I mean.
What'd you say?
Operating system,
since it's sort of said similar,
but more so an organism than an operating system because an operating system can
be dormant.
You could just shut it off and it sits there.
This thing is a system.
It's a living thinking system and that's why when I say like people that think
that the federal government has a handle on things that nobody's got a handle on
this,
this is out of everyone's control.
Well,
you're dealing with right now is massively accelerated human evolution,
human evolution of thinking and culture that's going on in an unprecedented
scale so fast that we can't recognize it while it's happening to us and at the
same time,
technology is moving in this impossible to catch direction.
It's out of everyone's hand now.
It's growing itself and unless we get hit by an asteroid or Yellowstone blows or
something,
something that wipes out most of the people on the planet,
we have to start with the cast of swamp people.
You know,
the cast of those gator hunters from swamp people,
them and the narrator,
they're the only people left in life.
Unless that happens,
lifts something that fucking catastrophic happens.
I could live in that world.
Do you live in the spot?
I could live in that world when I go watch swampy,
but I think,
which I like those.
Which of those women I would fuck
I was after a while.
All of them.
But those,
those swap women,
they need fucking subtitles and they're speaking English.
They're living in America speaking English and everything they say has
subtitles.
Yeah.
The king of the swamp has always got two subtitles.
That creole accent thing going on this,
because there is,
it's like the creole thing is,
is a whole different world down there,
man.
The real deal,
you're,
I mean,
when you get back in those people that when you live back in them woods,
it's a different life.
Yeah.
That French thing.
What was that fucking movie?
There was a movie where a bunch of dudes,
okay,
Brian helped me on this.
There was a movie,
God damn it was it Burt Reynolds was it,
it wasn't deliverance was deliverance.
No,
no.
There was a movie about creels and dudes that got crazy and shot at some do.
They thought it was fun and they shot at some dude in the swamp.
And
then the,
those people started hunting them.
Was it,
wait,
wait.
Was it uh,
uh,
was it like army and training in the swamp?
Yes.
Yeah.
I can't remember the name of this.
I know the movie you're talking about.
Ah,
they were,
they were reserves.
They were reserves.
Army reserves.
They were training in the,
in the Louisiana swamp.
And they took a shot at,
so I remember that movie.
Yes,
please.
Oh,
what was the name of that movie?
Wheat.
The name of that fucking movie.
I know you people know somebody got it out there.
That's gonna.
That's gonna make me crazy.
I guarantee you we will get that.
Jane.
I can see him with the southern comfort.
God.
Damn.
That's a good movie.
Netflix in that bitch.
I am too.
That got me scared as fuck those fucking Badass hillbillies.
Yeah.
You don't fuck around and that's like a dumb hillbillies man.
1981 that made me think of that.
Patrick Patrick Swayze movie with the hillbillies.
It's only got a 7.2
on the IMD be.
How dare you.
That was greatness.
That was a good move.
It's a Walter Hill movie.
Oh Shit.
That's incredible.
I didn't know that was a Walton real movie.
Holy Shit.
Wow.
Walter Hill did aliens,
right?
I thought aliens.
That's ready to least Scott Scott in it.
I think he was involved in it somehow.
Yes.
Was He,
does it say aliens?
Maybe a producer or something like that.
Aliens was John Carpenter,
right?
Didn't John Carpenter direct it?
I thought it was really Scott daily yen.
Oh,
aliens.
You're talking about.
Is that the second one?
I don't know.
It was originally meant to direct alien.
He was originally meant to direct alien,
but he didn't.
He's a producer and alien is he?
Yeah.
Okay,
but you don't really,
Scott did direct the aliens.
He also thought he did the first two.
He also did a hard times with Charles Bronson son.
That's a strong movie.
Did he produce it or directly?
I don't know what he did,
but he worked with,
uh,
Charles Bronson on hard times.
Just says it.
Here is a quote where he's talking about working with Charles Bronson.
Oh,
I see.
There's a list of,
maybe he's directed,
but yeah,
I shit let 48 hours.
Brewster's millions cross Brewster's millions heat Johnny handsome,
another 48 hours.
Johnny handsome.
Is that I'm Michael.
Mickey Rourke.
Mickey Rourke Warrior Forum,
Dude.
They rob banks or something like that.
Oh,
I'm not paying,
I think it was banks.
They robbed.
Wow.
So Southern Comfort,
man.
I remember as soon as,
oh,
I know what you're talking about.
That's a good drink to drink.
Train.
I drink wild Turkey.
I've been doing shots,
a wild Turkey lately.
Turkey and a little too much,
man.
I'm a Jack Daniels guy.
That's like Jack Daniels on steroids.
No,
and that's what happened to me.
I got so sick with Jack Daniels,
so I switched to Turkey and almost killed me because it's one a one at most bars
too,
because they always have the one on one.
That shit's very,
very,
very strong.
Yeah.
Keith Carradine powers booth,
remember powers booth and Fred Ward,
son Reema Williams,
whatever happened to Raymond Williams did the adventure begins Reema Williams is
never continued to Koreans got a big boost because of a Reema Williams.
So little man was the man.
He was the man.
He did fuck people up.
But its fingertips,
that whole thing on the statue of Liberty.
Yeah.
Then a squad of National Guard in an isolated Louisiana swamp must fight for
their lives when they're,
when the angle local Cajuns by stealing their canoes.
Oh that's what it was without.
They got separated or lost or something and they,
a certain group of them and they,
they did that.
They did shoot at somebody though.
They,
they shot somebody and one of them killed them.
One of them shot one of their boys and then it was on,
I remember that I was a good movie.
I remember liking him.
I was pretty young though.
I'm gonna rewatch it,
see if it holds up.
That was a very,
and then another fucking good movie that is kind of Cliche is deliverance and
other similar movie.
That's when Burt Reynolds was a bad motherfucker.
I put up a link on my Twitter the other day of a 70 year old bodybuilder.
Pull this fucking clip,
pull this clip.
You,
you,
you won't believe this,
but just,
just do youtube 70 year old bodybuilder.
This black dude.
And all I could think of is I watched that show fast and loud.
You ever watch that show?
Fast and loud car guys,
they build cars and they,
the guy,
uh,
Bill Burr has a really funny bit of,
I don't know if it's a bit,
but he's,
he talks about it really funny.
They um,
they,
they're always like buying cars off people and then fixing them up and reselling
them.
And the guys always like,
uh,
how much you want for the car and the guy's like 5,005 now.
I was hoping you going to say too.
And then they,
they,
you know,
anyway,
they go and they build this a smokey and the bandit car.
One of those old school Trans Ams.
They go to visit Burt Reynolds at his home to get them to sign the car.
Dude,
Burt Reynolds is only 78 years old.
Okay,
so he's only eight years older than this guy who's in this video lifting weights
and Burt Reynolds looks like he's dying.
Look at this guy.
This is mother fucker 70 backed that up,
backed it up.
Play that back again.
Hold on.
You got to see the beginning of it.
Look at this guy's body.
This motherfucker is 70 years old.
Are you shitting me?
He's doing dead lifts.
He's fucking 70 he's seven d seven zero mean his face looks kind of 70 ish.
But God damn son,
that dude's chiseled.
I don't care if he's on three.
I put them 50 ish,
like a hard facts and a hardcore 52 like you're a bad motherfucker.
Meanwhile,
he's 70 wow.
Just swole to the gills.
Burt Reynolds is only eight years old in this guy and when Burt Reynolds was in
his driveway,
he looked so bad,
he was hunched over CV.
You could pull up Burt Reynolds on fast and loud,
see if there's a youtube clip of it online anywhere.
But it was so depressing,
man,
because I was a huge fan of Burt Reynolds would.
I was a kid.
He,
you know,
deliverance especially.
That was a fucking phenomenal movie.
That was his first roommate hooper.
That's right.
Of course smokey and the bandit.
Those were fun movies,
man.
When I found out that he was Sharkey's machine machine.
That's right.
Without Hot Italian bitch.
Who was that hot Italian benefit domino or something like that wasn't in her
name.
She's a prostitute.
He fell in love with and he was just a cop.
African.
I'm crazy shit.
You find it anywhere.
It's sad man.
Look at him.
There he is.
Back it up a little bit so he could see him.
I mean they didn't show too much of them I think because they were trying to not
depressed everybody,
but he's like got this cane and he's,
he looks so old,
man.
It's weird.
And they had them at the areas looking,
I look.
Yeah.
Is that my car?
What good be
okay is selling cars.
How are you doing sir?
Richard Rawlings.
Hi Richard.
Nice to see.
I liked your show.
Right on.
Thank you sir.
Very nice to see you.
Or Aaron Kaufman.
Nice to meet you.
I'm really excited to be here.
He just got the shot of the day and uh,
he got it in though,
Dude.
Yeah,
burn.
Got It in.
That's wear and tear.
He put on those bones was a football player and he's young
and uh,
I know he,
he has some serious back injury to right.
Didn't he just got too many blow jobs?
He's stuck in that curl.
The orgasm
was pussy and cocaine at bodies.
Yeah.
Oh,
he did?
Yeah.
He had some pretty serious back injuries in the two thousands.
Poor guy,
man.
It's,
it's hard.
It's hard.
Was trying to pick up Lani answers.
Just tidies that's heavy.
Wasn't that his chick for our low,
he had a pill addiction.
That's it.
That's where it is,
man.
That Shit will rob you of your fucking vitality quicker than anything.
Yeah,
he had back surgery and then he got addicted to pills after the back surgery.
Oh listen ladies and gentlemen,
if you can avoid it,
if there's any way to avoid it,
don't get your back operated on.
I mean sometimes you can have to do it,
but always do it and take it from me personally,
I was advised to get back surgery and I went against it and I don't have any
back pain anymore.
I cured it up,
totally numb fingers,
pain throughout my older nerve down through my elbow,
everything.
And I was seriously thinking about it.
Cause if they cut you,
you know,
you heal up in a couple of months,
whatever and you're,
you know,
you don't have any pain anymore.
All that numbness is gone.
The bulging discs is sticking out.
But there's other ways to go about some of them.
Not all of them,
but some of those injuries,
there's other ways to go about it.
But so many doctors want to cut you right away.
They just want to cut you.
And I know not everybody can go through all the shit that I went to rehab it.
Um,
I'm well aware that I have the kind of free time that allows me to seek out
different kinds of therapy.
You know,
go get traction and get one of those things in my house with a hang by my ankles
and hang by my neck from a doorway.
But when I see people that have had surgeries,
man,
it seems to work out bad so often,
so many.
And that obviously a back injury is fucking bad,
period.
If you got some shit with fucking with your spine,
that's not good period.
No matter what,
whether it's an injury or whether it's a surgery,
it's like that whole area is just so delicate going in there and cutting it.
And that's,
that was uh,
there was another recent article about pill addiction,
about how many people who go in for like some serious surgery and then get on
some pills because the doctor prescribes you form.
How many people have like real withdrawals,
super common.
Like re most people get through it,
but real common that they have a hard time.
I'm not unsympathetic to that,
but it's also this,
it's these people use the pills beyond the need for them.
All right.
Because I was on dilaudid,
which is like that drugstore cowboy.
Yeah.
They all freaked up.
That's the shit of all shit.
And I remember being in the hospital for my heart surgery afterwards and
learning,
I was on this mission,
they had me on this machine.
I could medicate myself every so often.
And your brain starts to hear when it clicks over that you can go like,
you know when you can hit it again and,
and I would,
you know what I mean?
It was fun.
It was unbelievable.
All right.
And then I remember asking what it was and drugstore cowboy happens to be one of
my favorite movies of all time.
So when they told me dilauded,
I was like,
Oh shit,
fuck.
I'm like,
I'm fucked.
I'm,
I literally was like in the hospital thinking I'm fucked because this feels
good.
And I know as soon as I get out of here,
I'm gonna want more of this shit.
And I expressed the concern to the doctor and the doctor told me,
look,
as long as you're using pain medication to s to actually mask pain,
you can't get addicted to it.
It's the minute you use it and that pain isn't,
it's not to control the pain.
Like if you,
it's hard to explain what he'd doing,
he told me.
But that's basically the layman's terms of it is like as long as it's really
masking actual pain,
you're not going to get addicted to it.
It's when you like the pain gets a little less,
but you still think,
oh,
let me just take a little edge off it.
And you stay on that same strength painkiller instead of weaning yourself off.
Like,
that's why you should be monitored the whole time.
If you're taking pain medications,
I don't believe in them sending you home with an army of fucking pills cause
nobody gets,
first of all,
you can mess up just in your sleep by if you had a little pain,
you took a pill earlier but you're a little loopy and you don't know you took
that pill and next thing you know you're taking three of them at night and you
know sometimes accidentally you get hooked on him.
But some people just say like,
these feels so good and I'm so comfortable on my fucking couch,
let me keep taking them because I got 30 extras that I don't need.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
They,
they,
they're so quick to fucking pass those bitches out.
Oh yeah.
Some doctor's offices too.
I went to a great doctor for my nose.
I had a deviated septum repaired and I had no fucking pain when I'd tell you no
pain,
I'm not trying to be a tough guy.
And when it was over,
there was nothing like,
I'm sure while he was cutting me,
if I was awake,
he would have hurt like fucking shit.
But after it was over,
there was not much.
It was a little swollen and weird,
but he came,
he too fucking painkiller prescriptions too for two different things.
I had my wisdom teeth pulled.
Same kind of thing.
Excellent doctor,
right?
He prescribed me like 60 vicodins.
The next day I was eating burritos.
It was like,
wow,
this is,
I was expecting this worst pain in my life.
Everybody told me it was going to be the worst thing ever.
The wisdom teeth getting pulled was I was,
I was prepared for hell and I woke up the next day.
It was like,
this is great.
And I literally had those pills in my,
in my cabinet forever until I figured out,
and this was like 20 something years ago that a half a viking in an essay and a
glass of whiskey is a good time for a while.
You know what I mean?
And so I came very close to becoming like kind of strung out there on pills.
And so I caught myself literally like,
wait a minute,
this is getting out of hand.
Um,
and I was able to just,
you know,
I was,
I,
I luckily have that kind of personality.
I've never been really super addictive personality,
so I've been able to recognize a few times when I got close to like this could
get out of hand.
Yeah.
Luckily man,
I tell people that I smoked crack once.
What was that like?
It was,
it was bananas.
It was like the craziest,
greatest rush for like 35,
40 seconds.
And then it was gone and it was like I wanted more.
And a guy I used to live with was a cracked,
I won't even call him his dealer,
a seller.
He just kind of sold it.
He wasn't even dealing,
cause he wasn't even doing very well with crack.
And that's uh,
you know,
I don't even understand.
But so like one night I was just kinda chipped off a piece and I smoked some
crack.
Man.
I was curious,
man.
But I recognized right away,
Yo,
I can,
I know why people lose their lives behind the shit.
And you smoke crack?
Yeah.
What was that like?
I didn't like it.
I thought it was just,
it smelled weird and smell is off putting.
Yeah,
it taste is not good.
But like the rush,
I got it from it.
I was like,
Whoa,
for like a few and literally 30 seconds and then it was Kinda like gone,
but you wanted it to happen again.
And I was just like,
Nah,
I ain't fucking go in there again man.
It was abd rather.
I remember thinking I'd rather do cocaine because had like took,
we took our cocaine and made crack and I forget how to do it.
Like baking soda.
Freebase freebasing let me crack is just like automatic,
like pre made freebase that's what crack is.
I free base.
What's the difference between crack and freebase?
Nothing.
It's just they figured out a better way to,
uh,
easier,
cheaper way to make the free base.
Like you had to have ether and all this other shit and I don't know,
was it freeway,
Rick Ross?
Have you ever had him in fuck yeah,
we had him on a couple of,
that's right.
I'm just going to say it sounds familiar.
Yeah.
I don't know if he's the guy who actually invented the way they make crack on
the stove,
but he's one of the early,
early pioneers of it.
Well,
he's certainly one of the early pioneers of the,
the business aspect of it.
Hell yeah.
Do it.
Talks about the money that he made during the glory days,
but he's total government isn't,
isn't doing that right Joe?
The government wouldn't have anything to do with that.
That's why the government was not involved
in selling drugs in the inner cities of Los Angeles to find the contrast versus
the Sandinistas in Nicaragua.
They weren't doing that despite what Oliver North said,
Congress proved or who,
who,
who got po,
how'd they find out that they were selling drugs?
It was,
it was all in that and Oliver North scandalous and evolved around that Easton
thing.
Yeah.
Was the guy,
Rick Ross was the fucking guy who is in charge of all that shit in Los Angeles
and well,
it's your audience.
So they already know.
I don't have to qualify that.
It's not the rapper who stole,
stole his identity.
Isn't that crazy?
It's crazy though.
50 cent did the same thing.
Just his,
his drug dealer's dead.
Yeah.
50 cent is a famous famous drug dealer in New York.
No,
she,
yes,
absolutely.
Yeah,
I think I did.
Yes.
No Shit.
Well,
Jay Z is a guy named Jasso Wright who was a jazz.
Oh.
Uh,
I think that was his partner.
Like there used to be a rapper jazz though,
and Jay z was his DJ way back in the day.
Oh,
see,
I had thought it was that jazz.
I don't know much about it.
If they were drug dealing and whatnot back then.
I don't,
I w I'm not hip to that part,
but they had a hit like jazz.
Oh.
Had a song way back called Hawaii,
Hawaiian Sophie Hawaiians.
It was like big at the time.
It was like for the era,
it was a hit for sure.
He was supposed to be a really good rapper.
He wasn't,
he's still probably is.
There's a lot of guys that have slipped through the cracks that people,
I mean rap,
I'm sure Jay even at this point would acknowledge that,
you know,
some of his beginnings come from Jazz.
Those styles of rap.
Well everybody gets influenced by somebody else.
Absolutely.
Everybody.
I mean,
I always give up the,
uh,
my,
my influences,
but Boston comedians Kennison like without all those people that I was as though
it's actually,
you know,
that song ain't no nothing like the one I got you.
Has he done?
He's sings,
I believe he's the guy singing in the hug.
No one can do it bad if he's not the guy actually singing it in the video.
That's him really a big daddy Kane.
He's still around,
man.
He's doing yo big daddy Kane ain't making records.
But I'll tell you like this,
as far as rap shows go,
I guarantee you he's still putting on one of the best rap shows around.
The old classics has all his classics,
but it's like he still has his dancers.
They have,
they do like a classic,
like I would call it like almost like a Vegas if there was a hip hop Vegas act
kind of thing.
It's kind of that,
but not cheesy in any way.
But like there's a classic classic quality and then a word to it,
like the two dancers.
It's like an era.
He represents it and it's a great show to,
how about EPMD?
That's another band you don't hear about anymore.
Yeah,
well they had a lot of internal problems and broke up and got back together and
broke up.
Yeah.
I liked EPMD first of all because whenever the dude,
amazing rapper and all sides of speech impediment and is a bad actor Everlyn
yeah,
he's got a list and just spitting dope rhymes with no apologies for his list,
you know,
and,
and it's good to,
well the first one to do that was Kool g rap.
Kool g rap was great.
Kool g rap.
He had the craziest boss and he had the craziest lists of all,
didn't really go to his office.
He had a crazy list.
Man.
Didn't know.
Do you ever hear it?
Okay.
Michael Blue Blazers list.
That's the best because it's,
everything was song.
He talks like this and Opie and Anthony poked down standards and stuff.
Yeah.
I have a really cool g rap.
Had a real pull up a cool job,
pull up,
talk like sex,
cock blocking.
That's one of my favorite ones.
Pull up Kool g rap cock block and he's got a great song about trying to bang
this chick and her son,
his cock blocking
all.
Also to remember that Dude Kool g rap was one of my favorites.
Something.
He just fell off.
I don't know what happened.
Hey,
just,
you know,
it's like one of them things.
It's just,
it was an error in it,
you know?
Yeah.
But he was hot.
It's like one of the,
it's a youth sport,
you know what I mean?
That's what I try and tell me.
Why didn't you do?
Why you ain't rapping like Qsu?
I still ride my putting it into my songs.
I'm working into what I do.
My,
my version of hip hop and stuff.
It's like but to chase the,
the adoration of the youth that buys hip hop right now as it was ridiculous for
me cause I'm a 44 year old man to Kool g rap and Dj Polo operations.
The song
it's called operations.
Yeah.
That's your cost to USA operations.
CB.
This action usually results in broken friendships.
The following
cause this is where the essence
I'm trying to get at.
It
brings back memories.
This is great.
Everything is going.
This is
crazy.
This dude is like one of the revolutionaries of style
rap.
Like Kool g rap care is one in big daddy Kane really changed rap and Chuck d
those.
Cause before that it was like the run DMC [inaudible] pop,
pop,
a bias kind of just straight cadences.
And these guys all had different,
these different styles that they started working in.
And that's where a lot of everybody else started branching out and realizing
like there was more than one way to rhyme and one way to rap like Kool g rap,
big Daddy Kane,
krs one,
and Chuck d,
they,
they're the ones,
they're the forefathers of everything that goes on lyrically.
Now.
I,
I agree and I feel like there's,
there's something missing on a lot of people want to do this sort of,
uh,
this,
this hip hop hip hop has changed and a lot of ways today with is a lot of stuff
that they're calling hip hop that almost seems like dance music.
Yes.
And that's what it is.
It's,
it's
hip hop has been,
you know,
it's been opted man by their money.
You know what I mean?
The money there was,
there was money around back when these songs were being made,
but it wasn't ridiculous money that could,
it wasn't millions and billions.
It was thousands.
You know what I mean is like we were getting thousands of dollars back in the
day thinking like were bawling man.
I got a Nissan Sentra and a gold rope.
Motherfuckers for Shit you bought.
What's the first shit you bought when you started getting paid like a gold chain
from the Sloss and swap meet for text box for tick bomb.
What's that?
Remember the bongs,
the vortex bongs with that you had a tattoo.
The vortex clown graphics.
I'm sorry,
graphics.
There you go.
Graphics clown is just a,
I still have that.
I drew that when I was like 21
yeah,
it reminds me of it.
It looks like Eddie.
It's so old now.
It's fading like Eddie's face clown hat on.
I'm going to get Aaron Dellavedova to think finished the Musashi and fit it.
Figure out what to put at the top of it.
He's the same guy has done both of my arms.
I just got to get this bitch lasered off.
It's dice light.
You can go over that.
Yeah.
I don't want it though.
He prefers not to.
Aaron likes to have a clean slate.
He's a perfectionist.
He doesn't like to have to draw some shit that he doesn't want to draw just
because there's some old ink there.
He's like,
it's no big deal.
Just get it lasered a couple of times.
He's like,
it's pretty old.
It'll get off pretty quick.
Then you wait three months and then get to work.
I just have to design or rather come up with the idea and send it to him.
Whatever.
My idea is and he'll design with a top is you got to figure out what to do.
Check out this,
this,
this is what opie and Anthony was talking about.
The Michael Bublé lists.
You can keep that fucking song on in the background.
Make bublé sound tolerable,
but it's,
I got this lesson
right when he
does
that string around my,
are we going to get pulled up youtube for this?
You know what?
I think probably are we going to,
because we have that clip on there.
No,
it doesn't seem like no it does.
You know what I'm just thinking.
I think opie and Anthony got sent a fake audio file cause they like broke it
down and they have an always on the replay.
It's kind of
like sex.
I don't hear that.
That's weird.
You got to hear more of a song and I'm telling you the PM d but he made it.
You got to understand he made him and Eric sermon or comparable.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's interesting.
I think Eric sermon put it on a little bit more though because Kool g rap like I
think there was Kool g rap was before that.
Really?
Oh yeah.
Oh Shit.
I'm not saying he made up,
that's the thing.
I just think he let it go a little bit more.
Whereas Kool g rap might've worked to like try to not have it as bad when he was
recording Kool g rap.
So one of my all time and just let it go.
He said,
I got a lift and that's what's going to be,
I'm a big fan.
Axiom lit to content to be free and get down to the fans of VP.
Let me hear it here.
Empathy lab,
go walk the show.
Why?
Because right now I buy the shake,
convinced the ICPA is my name and my spouse to define your chair.
It's got too much tongue and too much lips struggling song.
I just get down and I go from my check.
One,
two,
one.
That was the jam now,
right to terminate the fork is heat.
Kim was one of the best
is another one that is young kids don't,
they don't respect enough.
Rakim follow the leader.
Oh,
he was a gun.
You know what?
I actually passed it.
That's one that was missing off that list.
He was fifth yes.
He should have been on that as for sure.
I totally spaced on him.
We just sit three hours.
He is like,
there is no Nas without rock camp period and Nas would definitely agree to that.
He,
he is definitely one of the fathers of remodel lyricists.
You got me turned on to nods and rewind and that's one of my favorite songs.
It's brilliant.
Right.
The way he set it up,
going from the bullet back into the gun,
the whole thing taking the the events and re record.
Right and Mike and all that.
Yeah,
that's some good shit man.
He,
Nas has some good shit nomadic.
Was that the name of that album?
It's still magic.
The first album it,
his album is universally,
the first album is universally recognized as one of the great albums of all time
aromatic.
Yeah.
He went through a period where stuff wasn't nearly as good for awhile.
It was interesting.
But what happened with him?
I think the,
the feud with him and Jay z like sort of inspired him to get better because JC
called some of his shit garbage and like,
you know,
nausea was like Whoa,
like wait,
you know,
they had this thing back and forth and then they got together and then they
worked it out.
It was ridiculous.
The ether was,
he went after it.
I just think nas was doing things and got,
you know,
he made some money.
You got to remember he made that first album when he was like 17 or something
man,
like Oh classic all time for the ages album at 17 or 18 years old tops.
When he was on his first record,
main source,
I think he was like 16 or 15 and he like destroyed everybody on it.
Yeah.
Live at the barbecue.
When I was 12,
I went to hell for snuffin Jesus.
I was like,
yeah,
he has some,
the greatest lyrics of all time.
Some of the greatest,
most thought provoking lyrics of all time.
The whole first album and many albums of his sense were great.
But that first one was just dumb.
It's like when you capture it in the can,
that lightening and you've got,
you know,
all of it's perfect.
That Alpha is damn near perfect.
Did you ever seen the one,
there's one album that is not universally thought of as being one of his best,
but the one with him,
with the,
uh,
the Sphinx face,
what does it,
what does it like some sort of Egyptian moat to that?
The one with a,
you could hate me know and all that on there.
I don't remember.
I don't know album names as well as I know the song and he's got a song on it
called,
um,
there's,
there's w welcome to the new world is one of my favorite nas songs that nobody
ever talks about and it's,
it's him talking about,
let me see.
Let me find his,
um,
his Wikipedia here.
It's,
it's a song you never hear people talk about,
but it's him talking about the,
was that it was written?
It might be.
It might be that.
I think you might be right.
Let me see here I am,
see if you can find Brian CV.
We'll,
we'll,
we'll end with this.
How much time we got left?
Seven minutes.
You're on timers now at three hours.
Return to a pumpkin.
We only have three hours at three hours.
The recordings over play a place.
I can remember Carlton,
we went longer than three hours.
Dude,
we crushed it today.
Today we went with,
we accelerated time.
We made three hours.
Seem like two hours.
I thought he was wrong the other road.
The road is that song?
No,
no,
no.
It's called a welcome to the new world.
Welcome to the new world.
Welcome to the new road.
Do you find it go out on some nausea?
Yeah.
Let's listen to this shit because this is like back when Roy Jones Jr was the
baddest motherfucker on earth.
This is like some,
I think it was like the 90s,
I want to say nineties cause this nineties 90.
But it's about technology and the future
were the that I think I know the song you're talking about,
but I have to hear it to be refreshed.
It's really interesting because um,
it's on Africa.
So this is in the era when like he was going with production that I think more
than labels and stuff,
we're looking for that pop appeal.
I think he wasn't picking his beats wisely in this little error that he got.
I think that's when the only time he got slowed down is when,
as I think some wrong choices were made.
I don't think it had anything to do with his stuff or his lyricism.
Yeah.
See,
this is like,
I've never been a fan of outright ripping old songs like this.
I've never been a fan of it.
I mean if you do it collaboratively and like,
like there's,
there's producers like guy like DJ premier,
they would take something like that and chop it up into smaller pieces and turn
it into something new.
I'm a fan of that.
But when you just take an entire riff and like recreate it and kind of almost
copy the song but just make it into a wrap,
like versus with like even steal their hooks,
you know?
Right.
I think pocketed it with like Bruce Hornsby is just the way it is.
I that never been a fan of those things.
That's been not,
that's probably why that song wasn't so prevalent in my mind.
I,
yeah,
I'm a real big fan of what he's saying in it.
I did fantastic,
but I agree with you.
It's not the best B.
It's kind of annoying.
Listened to,
there was a little era his,
we got to,
the production got to clean for me.
Like,
Nah,
it should be on a grimy ass.
You know what I mean?
Like once he came back with ether and then he came back with the,
where he chopped up Apache for that made you look.
Yeah,
that's where he should be saying.
You know what I mean?
Like I think the record labels and people got some and radio and the success.
You want it when you're young and you first get success,
you want to,
you're listening to the people around you and they're telling you,
you got a copy of that to keep getting your success.
And you become either one of two things.
You know,
a guy that,
a band that just makes that formulaic album every time and you'll have some
success for awhile or you fall off the face of the planet.
You know what I mean?
Or you go back to what you know and be the genius you are and don't trust what
everybody else was saying and trust your guts.
And Nas,
I'm sure even knew he needed to be on the beat.
He's
back where he should be.
He's been there for a minute now.
He's back completely.
His last few cds were fantastic.
Absolutely.
Yeah,
he's his ether.
I think I've been enjoying ever since.
I think you're right about,
I think Jay z definitely sparked some fire under his ass for sure.
Yeah.
I think when someone calls you a garbage,
you just go,
well,
there was a lot more said than me.
I don't know how close he had his attention you paid,
but there's a lot of things about people's babies mamma's getting fucked up.
Like you know,
like Jay even apologized on radio in New York.
There's a lot of like hip hop,
little folklore around like is Mont Jay's mom supposedly made them go on the air
and apologize for some shit.
He said there was a lot of that going around.
There was a lot more than just a wraps going on.
It kind of goes back to what we were talking about earlier that you said that
you need a producer,
you need someone to argue with.
Sometimes the guy is good as Nas challenged me.
Yeah.
Like Yo,
it'd be that's not as good as it could be or that maybe that's not the right
choice for that song.
And,
and the way I've always looked at it as if I was passionate enough about it and
it was opposed to be in there,
I would fight for it.
Right.
But if you brought it up and I even questioned him for a thing second,
take it in and say maybe then maybe then it deserves to be Moldova and thought
about.
It's also when you can find out whether or not your representation is right for
you.
Because if they don't know what you're doing,
they try to change what you're doing.
Like Ari had a problem with a dude that was working with him where he has,
Ari has this fucking hilarious bit that we really happened when he was on his
long walk over this giant bridge in Sydney and he had to take a shit like in the
middle of this bro,
there's no turning back.
He was going to shit his pants.
Something was going to have,
no matter what he did is no turning back.
You're in the middle of this bridge.
Takes an hour to walk back to where the fuck you were.
Ah.
So he's like stuck and it's,
it's a hilarious bit.
And his,
his Ma,
I don't know who it was.
They were like,
you got to drop that.
It's a shit joke.
You shouldn't do shit jokes.
She was like,
what?
Like did you pay attention to that?
Like that's a,
that's a joke about being a human being and being in a real situation.
That act.
Get the fuck Outta here.
And he got rid of the dude.
People who have made careers out of shit jokes man.
Yeah.
There's nothing wrong with a shit joke.
If it's a good one.
Hell No.
Every joke,
every subject is on the,
the,
the menu.
If it's Mr Hankey would never have existed if somebody listens to that.
Exactly.
And on that note,
thank you all.
Keep donating please.
The link is on my Twitter.
I'm going to keep tweeting it.
I put it up as well.
I put the link up and I'll have you do it some more.
Please.
I would,
I'll bug you in a couple of days,
couple of days after that.
I will help no doubt.
And uh,
let,
let everybody know.
If you,
uh,
you got it and you seen it on my Twitter,
please retweet it.
Get it out there.
Please.
Help me.
Help me out to,
and folks,
ladies and gentlemen,
let everybody ask him for help.
Exactly.
Let everybody know that it's a,
it really is positive,
really as possible,
rather,
and it's very close to curing this disease.
You can actually claim to have helped cure this disease.
I,
my bets are within 10 years,
they are going to have this wrapped up.
I believe you follow Everlast on Twitter.
Oh Gee.
Everlast on Twitter.
That's,
Oh gee.
Everlast on Twitter.
And where can they see you in Australia?
Australia.
I'll be all over the place.
I,
there'll be dates all up on,
on my Twitter and all that stuff and the Instagram little posts,
uh,
you know,
come check me out.
I'll be in Europe afternoon.
You know the states I'm going to keep you all posted.
Beautiful.
It's always a blast.
Always a great time.
Anytime it's been too long since the last one I gotta be,
I gotta be more diligent.
We will do it more often without a doubt.
Uh,
thank you everybody.
Thank you to the sponsors.
Thanks to Squarespace.
Go to squarespace.com and a entering the code word Joe and save 10% off your
first purchase.
Get a free trial and 10% off your first purchase,
squarespace.com entering the code word Joe.
Thanks also to stamps.com go to stamps.com enter in the code word J r e n get
your no risk Twila,
Twila,
while Eric B's got me fucking slipping road on this swing.
Yeah,
followed the leader and a $110 bonus offer,
including a digital scale and a up to $55 of free postage.
Thanks also to [inaudible] dot com that's o n and it makers of Alpha brain,
Trump tech,
sport and new mood.
Use the code word Rogan.
Save 10% of any and all supplements.
Um,
March 15th.
When am I?
No,
14th 14th grand prairie,
Texas.
That's right outside of Dallas with a Ari Shaffir and Duncan Trussell,
the Verizon theater.
Come get some.
And then I'm in Miami April 3rd,
I'm,
I'm in Orlando April 18th with Joey motherfucking Diaz.
And then I'm at Baltimore April 25th with Joey motherfuck ideas and uh,
Brian would,
what are you shows?
I got a weekend at La Jolla comedy store.
It's going to be January 28th and March 1st,
which is a Friday and Saturday with Tony Hinchcliffe,
Eleanor,
Sarah Wine Shank,
and a bunch of people you could back in time to do that one.
He [inaudible] Mowgli.
The comedy store in La Jolla is one of the great all time rooms,
far as ways to design one of the great all time rooms and a real stuffy
community.
So it's nice to go there and sling some fucking cum all over the walls.
Poop.
We love the fuck out of you people.
Thank you everybody for tuning in tomorrow.
The Great Ari Shaffir will join us and hopefully Wednesday we'll have Campbell
Mclaren,
my former boss,
and one of the original producers of the ultimate fighting championship.
We'll see if we can get him on a Wednesday.
If not,
we'll get somebody else.
All right.
The train goes on.
We love you bitches.
See you soon.
[inaudible].